This guy literally took his schizophrenia directly from a beautiful
mind. That's who he thinks he is. >> And that's his reason
why he doesn't get his schizophrenia treated ever for 15 years
is because he's just like, I don't this is it's not as bad as
this guy a movie. And in fact, your exact statement on February
5th of 2025. So after these allegations were made up is lip fillers.
They do make your lips look, but the problem is anyone who has
lip fillers cannot suck A WORTH A DAMN. IT SUCKS BECAUSE IF they're
sucked too hard, it'll fill up like a balloon on Tuesday on Macy
Day's parade. [__] their lip fillers. IS THAT CORRECT?
OH NO. THE NEXT QUESTION. SIR. SIR, have you ever eaten the box?
All right. Mr. Porier, please call your first witness.
Mr. Porier's responding calls. Drum roll, please,
ladies. And gentlemen, biggest piece of [__] alive,
ladies and and gentlemen, the twotime piece of
>> goes to
LET'S BRING ON THE 6'7 or whatever the hell he lies about, John
Now, I know a lot of it um I know a lot of you guys are going
to want me to do tech voice like this dude and talk like this.
I'm not going to do that because what I was told in court is
Techone literally tried to talk like this the entire time in
a very soft tone. Do you swear to tell the truth? Know the truth.
I'll help you God. >> I do.
>> Hey dude. >> All right. John, if you could please
introduce yourself for purposes for the record. Yeah. My name
is John Robertson. I'm um 32 years old and I make YouTube videos.
Okay. Going to December of 2022. This was your only source of
income. Everything, sir. This was your job? Yes, sir. And this
is when you met Pink. Um, I met Pink via a Twitter message that
she sent me through one of our mutual friends. But Jay recommended
that I talk to her. Jay recommended big that she would talk to
me and she shot me the message. She referenced I believe she
referenced Jay in in the message and I was like, "Okay." But
she did send me a message via Twitter after that. I'm I'm not
a big party guy, so I was just going through the motions. Yeah.
Uh we started talking in the DMs and very quickly I found out
that she likes two of my favorite things which are uh anime and
video games.
Sure.
And I thought, "Wow, a very attractive woman is talking to me
and she likes anime and video games and she's really nice. Let's
hang out." I I don't think I went into detail on why that was
that night and she asked me what I was into and I just said I
like long tongues. And then she puts her tongue out, points to
her mouth and she says like this. And it was the most forward
thing I've ever experienced in my entire life. I didn't really
know what to do, but I was like, "Wow, this is very straightforward,
Kchan."
Which I kind of was expecting because I knew she had a So you
FOUND THAT ATTRACTIVE? OH,
DUDE. IT WAS SMOKING HOT. SHE'S A >> JESUS CHRIST. MIZ,
YOU'RE BLOWING. HOLY. >> OKAY. And because I knew >> this
guy This guy's crazy. This guy's going nuts.
So you found that attractive? >> OH, ABSOLUTELY,
DUDE. IT WAS SMOKING HOT. SHE'S A SWEET ASS. OKAY. And what month,
what year was this? This was um to my best of knowledge, late
December, early January. Okay. So, at some point does she move
in?
Yes, sir. She moved in very quickly. Pink and I, it's her relationship
accelerated at the break neck speed. She invited me over to Christmas
dinners with her family like maybe like four or five days after
we started speaking and and me and my buddy Laura went to her
family's house and it was beautiful Christmas. Her family is
actually very kind. I I didn't really have that much of a functioning
family. So wait a minute. I thought that you and your dad were
very close. Don't wait. So being invited, when did she move in?
It seems like you had a pretty functioning family. Your family
was so function I just wanted to see your car all day. Oh, really
quickly. She would frequently complain about her house and I
had already flown in for my other buddy Lara to stay with me
for free because he was struggling and you know I I don't like
being alone. So I let him move in with me for free. And then
Pink said um that her sorry I don't like saying her name anymore.
Just gives me the heeie-jeebies that her house and um she didn't
really have anything to do about it. She couldn't just move out
because she couldn't afford it. >> And I said um hey if
anything you need to make your life better I'll I'll do it. If
you need money I got you. because there was this funny time she
was in her house and she was like very afraid because there was
a cockroach and so I I I came into my car and
dude this is so gay man
that doesn't matter
that doesn't matter. I I I'm sorry
and I can't help but notice it. I don't give a how much you cared
about her being scared of a cockroach.
We're talk about salt,
not about you speeding over because there was a cockroach there.
One has nothing to do with the other. Are you out of your mind?
Well, yes. Okay, he is out of his He's literally out of his mind.
They don't have any
Wait, there
he's suddenly flying down the highway.
>> I sped. I'm not going to lie. I >> Yes. Sorry.
>> I sped pretty bad. I was sl like I don't know like 3
m over the speed limit and I got pulled over that night and I
told the officer you know what what the guy says why are you
speeding I said well officer it was
for a girl this girl that I like you know she's got cockroaches
and he says
no no problem sir I get it lets me off dude
lets me off really
I don't think so that's like an everybody clapped moment right
there why is he doing that in court? THIS IS A TOTALLY unrelated
This is a totally unrelated story. The [__] is this
guy
Then the officer said, "Listen, I get it.
Here, I'm going to write you a thing. Nobody will give you a
ticket. You go 90. Don't Don't even go 80. Go 90." I
Okay, it would make sense. Okay, if Techome was like, "No, I
got to go see a girl. Look, here's her Instagram." And the officer's
like, "Oh, I get it. Get on. Get on over there, son. I
Okay.
Um, did you already watch past the point when Techone talks about
No, we haven't gotten to that point yet. We have not gotten to
that point yet.
Hold on." He like turns the siren on. Hold on. We'll get you
there, son. We'll get you there.
All the way. What's the address? We'll get you there fast. Okay.
I think you might need a helicopter. Can we call in Can we call
in a helicopter for this >> You want us to believe that
you were driving over the speed limit and you told the officer
that she had cockroaches and he let you go by just saying I get
it.
He didn't. >> It's just so inappropriate to play the video.
Officer, listen. Officer, this girl has cockroaches and I need
to get over there and help her out. Okay.
>> Girls cockroaches at her house and >> I need to
go over there and help right
Okay.
All right, son. You got to You got to get out of here. You need
directions. Can I help you? Can I please escort? Okay. We're
calling in two cars. We're going to get you there fast. Okay.
You do need to help this woman out. >> Tell you slow down.
He didn't. Uh
he he was not like, "Bro, what the It's just cockroaches. Relax."
He says >> the officer is like, "That's the most story
I've ever heard." Um, are you are you healthy, son? Are you are
you okay? Realistically, Tekone actually got pulled over by nothing.
Okay, he just hallucinated the cop. Hallucinated the situation.
He really believes it happened though. He saw it all. He saw
it all for real. He just pulled over on the side of the highway.
Okay, there was no cop. He made this up, but he doesn't >> He
get it and lets me off.
I do not believe that story in the slightest. In the slightest.
I don't believe that story. I'm sorry. That is a lie. I went
like, look at him try to like do this. I, you know, I sped pretty
bad. I went like 80 in like a 65. Bro, you're in Austin, Texas.
Everyone goes 80 miles an hour in 65s. That's not that you don't
get pulled over for that. That never happens. No one gets pulled
over for going 80 and a 65 at night. That's not That's not the
case. It does not happen. They don't pull you over for that.
They don't
like you get pulled over for going 120. You get pulled over for
going 100. But in Texas at night, dude, the roads are nothing.
No. No cop is pulling you over for going 80 and a 65. It's just
not happening. And if he does, he's a real [__] officer.
And he's not just going to say, "Oh, go for it, bro. She's the
one."
Gives me like a warning. And then I go over there and I pick
her up. Uh well he said uh that the officer says he gives him
like a warning and then I go over there and I pick her up and
I bring her back to my house and then I say >> wait hold
on is miss running uh pugly >> why don't you just so I'm
imagining techone um came through like the Kool-Aid guy bumped
swam through her wall and said oh yeah grabbed her as there was
like a cockroach on the ground and she's like I love you tactone
and then they went back to his place and basically it was true
love at first sight and that was the end of the movie. That's
what I'm imagining Tekken's basically believing.
>> I love that literally everybody's reaction to this story
being told is the exact same bar for bar just like everybody
could tell he's obviously lying. You think the judge couldn't
tell he's obviously lying? You think his own lawyer couldn't
tell he's obviously
Literally everybody there he like has no social awareness at
all. There was a quidd proquo that the expectation was that pink
was living with you in your house rentree that she had to provide
[__] to you. Is that true Mr. Teto? Not even in the
slightest. Okay. Did you have a male roommate that you were living
with? Yeah. Loro.
Okay. Okay.
The question can't possibly be
I mean assuming he's
Okay. which again is obviously not true, but he believes it or
he he at least sells that.
Did you make did you make that guy you?
No, I didn't make the male roommate of mine as a head and I didn't
make my male roommate me for free rent. Oh, well,
Miss Judge, I rest my case. Surely, if he was going to make people
him for rent, this man would have had to him, too. No. >> Did
he pay rent? Never once. Okay, sounds like a silly question.
Was he expected to provide you in exchange for living in your
house? Wasn't expect >> Wait, was he was his mod Oh, so
this guy was doing work for him anyway. Oh, just kidding. Doing
mod work is not work. I I would never pay people for that. >> Did
Okay, you and Pink were in romantic relationship. Is that correct?
Yes. Okay. Was it intimate?
>> I I actually really enjoyed it. She was very kind. She
was very quirky. And obviously, she had some issues, but I'm
okay with that. I love helping people through their problems.
So, I was more than willing to help Pink with whatever she needed.
Bro, I never ever want to hear that Kaisen is performative. Okay.
Was it?
Yeah. Okay. It was It was the most relationship I've ever had.
>> Okay. As this relationship progressed, was she also
in streaming? Yes. Was she and I realize there's a lot of kind
of different worlds on the internet? Was she had her own space?
Were you invested in helping her grow on the online brand? Abs.
Absolutely, sir. Okay. Like her every one of my other colleagues,
it's people want to find success in this world. I like helping
them do that. And Pic is actually really very funny and she's
very good on her streams. Okay. Did you leverage relationships
that you had in the industry?
Dude, it's um
I just feel so weird. Listen,
I feel like Techone did this with a lot of women, okay? I just
feel like this was his thing.
Never hurts to have a hot woman owe you a favor. I feel like
that's his philosophy or something. Okay. >> On her behalf,
can you give some context? Um what do you mean I that I leverage
relationships? That's not true. Did you by this point in time
you have been in the online industry for
streaming industry? You have connections with the industry. Is
that accurate? Yes, sir. Okay. Did you contact people that you
knew in the industry to attempt to amplify her viewership? Of
course. I still love her. Oh, okay. Yeah. I tried to make her
have friends. She didn't really have too many friends. So, I
tried to help her make friends. I invited, you know, some people
who I thought she'd get along with to the house and I introduced
her to everybody I know. Okay. Was there ever an expectation
that because of this assistance that you provided that there
was a quidd proquo?
G Wilickers? No. There was expected to return with the favors.
No sir. Okay. Was this Did you ever threaten Pink with Blank
or uh Blank if the relationship ended that you would destroy
her in the industry?
Takes off his hat. No sir. As a matter of fact, when we split
up, there was an idea that maybe we could just >> Okay,
he is bringing the hater energy. He didn't bring it on the other
stuff. >> Just as friends. >> Mr. Such a theater
kid. It's bro, the camera thing is
I I kind of I do regret not having a camera. We have to figure
stuff out though still. >> But my friends advised me against
it, but no, I would I would never do that. >> Okay. At
some point, were you made aware Jessica, your ex-wife, that there
was some Did she ask you if there was a better than me or words
to that effect?
>> Yes, sir. Okay. And what was that? To my best knowledge,
I want to say it was sometime maybe two or three months before
or two or three months after Pink and I started dating. So maybe
March of whether it would be 2023 or Yeah, probably March of
2023. Probably somewhere around that time. Okay. There was a
very uncomfortable period of time. Okay. Was that information
related to Pink? Did you tell Pink about the conversation that
you had with your wife?
Well, I tried not to let Pink know for maybe a week or two beforehand
cuz Pink is very sensitive. And so I tried to deal with the issue
beforehand before she had to deal about it because if there's
a problem, I'm going to attempt to solve it. >> Yeah, this
guy. So this guy's like totally making a mockery. The pink thing.
Yeah, I was
I honestly I just rather not even draw attention to him. Sounds
like a total >> looking back on it. I probably should have
told her earlier, but God, I was just at church camp and I thought
that I could have dealt with it myself. And so I didn't tell
her immediately but I did tell her and to my expectancy Pink
did not receive it well and I don't blame her for it as well.
It's very scary that myself about it because >> Hold on.
I was looking I was looking at the roommate thing >> to
say it was >> so you made aware but Jessica your ex-wife
there was some she
was some >> ex-wife that there was some did she ask you
if there was a better than me or words to that effect?
>> Yes sir. >> Okay. And what was that? To my best
knowledge, I want to say it was sometime maybe 2 or 3 months
before or two or 3 months after Pink and I started dating. So
maybe March of >> whether it would be 2023 or Yeah, probably
March of 2023. Probably somewhere around that time. Okay. There
was a very uncomfortable period of time. Okay. Was that information
related to Pink? Did you tell Pink about the conversation that
you had with your wife?
Well, I tried not to let Pink know for maybe a week or two beforehand
cuz Pink is very sensitive. And so, I tried to deal with the
issue beforehand before she had to deal about it because if there's
a problem, I'm going to attempt to solve it. And looking back
on it, I probably should have told her earlier, but God, I was
just at church camp
and I thought that I could have dealt with it myself.
>> Uh, so I didn't tell her immediately, but I did tell
her.
Okay, you didn't tell her immediately. Please, timelines. Please
for the love of God try to get timelines
right. So it's I he is saying she asked you is she yes your ex-wife
there. So did she ask you is she better than me or to that effect
two to three months. So March is when when when
techone hears >> probably March didn't tell her immediately
but I did tell her and to my expectancy pink did not receive
it well and I don't blame her for it as well. It's very scary.
>> Yeah that's a reasonable action if that's fair. Yes.
that she was upset about the notion that of course that there
had been some recordings that she didn't know about. Of course,
no woman would ever want that. >> Dude, I I feel like I
can hear Tone. Of course. Of course. Of course. I feel like I
can I could see him. Of course. I I could I can hear him like
do this incredulous tone. Of course. Of course. Were he like
upticks at the end? >> Okay. You were you aware when the
report that the to the ender police department I I was sir I
was heavily discouraged her not to because I'm horrified of my
ex to be honest with you. >> Okay. And I wanted to just
try to move on but pink is a very when when she gets her mind
on something she's going to do it. So against my wishes she went
ahead with it. >> Am I the only one who like
did the lawyer coach him on this at all?
Why? I don't think the lawyer coach him. He's talking in the
exact like Cavalier way he always does. I can It's like he's
on stream. I understand he might be talking with the softer voice,
but he's like performing. He's talking the same way he does on
stream. He is not speaking like directly. I feel like he didn't
get coached on this testimony. It's like, what were you doing,
man? How are you not getting coached on this at
Like, it's all this performative [__] you do on stream.
It's not It's not businesslike. You're you're like it it just
baffles me that you would pay this much. Apparently he had five
lawyers. Apparently he went to multiple law firms about this.
This has been the only thing occupying his thoughts. He has been
streaming and he just didn't prepare for
>> Okay. And I would think she's similarly with the lawsuits.
Yes. Is that fair? Yes. Okay. Were you aware of the lawsuit of
the lawsuit between Pink and and Frame? Yes. Oh, I was I was
very aware. I heard about it every day. Okay. And the lawsuit
is filed June 2024. Uh uh-huh. You're aware of the allegations
in the application for a protective order? Yeah. Specifically,
an incident that is alleged to have occurred in March of 2024
and another incident that's alleged to have occurred in March
28, May 28th or 29th of 2024. And you're aware of the allegations
in the application? Yes, sir. I want to ask you under oath, are
those allegations true? So, Tek right there says he never had
sex with Pink one time. In two years, two and a half years of
dating, they never had sex one time. Yo yo
>> So this lawsuit that Pink filed, she discloses how rumors
and just kind of online chatters about this these alleged
>> rumors and just kind of online chatter about this kind
of thing, these alleged recordings that your wife had, how that
was affecting her ability >> your wife had now that was
affecting her ability to get sponsors, how it was affecting her
ability to >> Oh man, Miz Miz just hasn't streamed for
like five hours reading
maybe ever. I I I see this fatigue and I get this fatigue when
I'm doing like a big long stream. It is hard after you've done
like three hours of reading to keep going. He is like consistently
messing up words now. This is not like before. We were psyched
about the miz reading before. I might have to go I might have
to start filling in cuz he's um he's misreading quite a bit.
But it's rough. It's rough. He's been this is a quite a performance.
5 hours of reading just this text only
is solid >> signage quickly with mythicus talent things
like that. >> Did you see that in real time? How has it
affected her? Of course, I spent the majority of my days when
I >> I don't know. Wait, I don't even know >> whether
that was me or her family trying to make sure Pink was okay.
That's kind of all >> I was thinking the guy who linked
it. >> I can absolutely vouch that. you know, with those
recordings, it's made things a little bit difficult because,
you know, it was told to me allegedly that the recordings were
sent to the heads of Mythic Talent and you know, Mythic Talent
already saw that I had a history with my ex-wife and that they
were kind of hesitant on it if I was going to date somebody now
new because, you know, they didn't want to repeat on that. And
yeah, so it definitely did slow things down for her. Absolutely.
But I attempted to help her in every step of the way. Was that
stressful for her going through that process? So, he's basically
saying that no one wanted to trust her. I think it would have
been stressful for anyone. I I felt for her. I felt horrible
for her because she trusted me and I tried
Dude, it's so performative. It's so insanely performative. M
is nailing the performance, too. Miz is like perfectly
perfectly calibrated right now. I said he was he was lagging.
He's only lagging because he is putting on a perfect performance
of how fake and gay Tee is being right now. Trying to show how
concerned he was for her.
seriously. >> Which were sent to the heads of Mythic Talent
and you know, Mythic Talent already saw that I had a history
with my ex-wife and that they were kind of hesitant on it if
I was going to date somebody now new because you know they didn't
want to repeat on that and yeah, so it definitely did slow things
down for her. Absolutely. But I attempted to help her in every
step of the way. Was that stressful for her going through that
process? So he's basically saying that no one wanted to trust
her. I think it would have been stressful for anyone. I I felt
for her. I felt horrible for her because she trusted me and I
tried every very hard to make sure she was okay and I just felt
like an idiot because she was very stressed, very scared. Would
go in her room and she would scream and whail and break things.
And it was very scary because I didn't blame her because I understood.
But yes, it was very hard for her. It was hard. The relationship
was very good until the stress of the ex-wife, of course. And
it
>> fair to say that it stressed your relationship with
her. Yeah. Okay. Things have been going good until February 2024.
Yes. >> Wait, the stress of the ex-wife to you then? The
stress of the ex-wife to you, not to her because I think it was
March 2023 when you told her about the videos. So, it was the
stress of the ex-wife to you that things were going good until
that happened. >> And is it fair to say that the investigation
and the lawsuit that that that kind of precipitated the relationship
kind of fail falling apart?
>> Yes. Pink and I's relationship was very fun. We play
games. We like the same things. But when Pink is worried about
something, it just
I'm sorry. It consumes her.
>> He's Where's his camera?
>> Okay. To where soon every conversation was just Okay,
I'll hear it again. And I knew it was scary. So, I wanted to
let her vent. I would take her to the bathroom and I would sit
her down and I would put on the water for background noise and
try to calm her because
that's
>> her down and I >> that's what calmed me down.
>> Pink has a hard time expressing herself. So I would
give her bro I I think it's just like some kind of particularly
weird [__] to go where you're accused of assault.
It's a protection trial, a protective order hearing for salt,
like a salt protective order and to go like start talking about
who she is, how she feels, like you know her, like you know what's
best. Like it's just it's just weird, man. You're being accused
of like stalking and assaulting this person. Pink has a hard
time expressing herself, so I would like give her a marker or
a crayon to like draw how she shut the up, man. like a marker
or crayon like draw how she feels so I could easily more easily
understand her. But yes, it made the relationship very difficult
to where once making a lot of good memories just kind of became
Pink's a wreck and how do I as a man take care of her?
And were you aware of some of the kind of mental health stuff
was going on with her? Yeah. Okay. And
Yeah.
Was that when you found out she was going to Austin Oaks? No.
Was that something that you were supportive of? I was blatantly
aware of everything Pink had stressing her out, everything she
was dealing with. You know, my previous partner had things that
they had to deal with as well. But I took it as is. If I gave
up on this person, you know, who am I when I have my own issues?
Who am I to give up on somebody because they have >> Dude,
I can't even
It's so disgusting performative. Like, the whole thing is just
this weird gross performance.
There's nothing tangible here at all.
Bro, he's like trying to win an Oscar on the stand right now.
It's just
his partner had things that they had to deal with as well. But
I took it as is. If I gave up on this person, you know, who am
I when I have my own issues? Who am I to give up on somebody
because they have their own issues? So, I tried helping her with
it. Sometimes successful, sometimes not. But I gave it my all
and that's pretty much all a guy can do.
Okay. when you broke up the first time.
>> dude. I gave it my all until this
tweeted about me. Until this tweeted about me, I gave it my all.
Then then it was war. Then it was like, there's just no way to
bridge that gap of like, okay, she tweeted about you. Now it's
war. Oh, you're so sensitive. You have your own issues and you
you really want the best for her. Oh, she tweeted about you.
This
Are you serious? Like, who could possibly buy this? Nobody believes
you. You're so unable.
>> Dude, there was I want to clarify. There was three times,
dude. Once I believe Pink had forgotten about. She has a bad
memory. There was one where Pink wanted me to have try to have
and I swore to her that I would try and I did and it just didn't
work. I was too afraid of
It's not a dude dude. Dude, this guy's got illicit medications
in every variety. Okay, this guy's almost certainly on like ompic
everything imaginable. You couldn't get some Viagra and help
your lady out one time, dog. One single time. Close your eyes,
pretend it's an okay, just close your eyes, pretend it's a mouth.
I don't know, man. >> Thing to take lightly. It's not a
guy that sleeps around and it's, you know, what if I get her
pregnant? I is is it genuinely the case that Teton is just a
homo in total denial? I I almost wanted to suggest this theory
earlier on Nick Andros and I mean I get how some people don't
want to hear this, right? Or some people don't want to they don't
want to denigrate like his
um his childhood trauma, but like is that not just a cope to
deal with the fact that you're not attracted to women that like
your your sister rubbed her crabsinfested snatch on you one time?
You're like I'll never touch of a ever in my life. I I just feel
like the biological imperative takes over there. No,
unless there was some other reason you're possibly or possibly
not born with. Okay.
You just didn't want to do that.
I I truly believe he's just gay. I I think he's a gay man in
denial. I
It makes so much more sense. It really
Okay. And I think the ways he was able to overcome that and become
like a uh like more straight
is just being like a straight up like total gooner like being
totally like totally goonfueled of like making everything and
then maybe he could kind of get it up for a woman kind of thing.
I don't know. I don't know. This guy's got weird deviency going
on. Is is not sure what to say.
I'm not a guy that sleeps around and it's you know what if I
get her >> I cannot believe he said this under oath. Your
>> honor, let me swear on this Bible. I
I was just too afraid of committing.
>> I believe you said this under oath. Like what the He
said, "What if I get her pregnant?" You couldn't just wear a
You know, you couldn't just have where worn a condom and her
you had to think what if you get her pregnant. I is that the
Is that the absurd thing here? Or is it not the I was too afraid
of committing
in general?
It's not a thing to take lightly,
bro.
It's Is he trying not to talk about Is he like getting his story
swapped around? Just Dude, Tone is like forgetting his own story
here. The reason he doesn't want to do the reason he's scared
of it is because of his childhood trauma. It shouldn't be stuff
around, oh, what if I get her pregnant? What if um Yeah, it couldn't
be anything like that. They make fimble. Come on,
>> Bro, the chat needs to move off the microphone jokes.
The microphone jokes are not
they're not good even. You got to have better jokes. I'm >> not
going to lie. The unfortunate reality is that I >> No,
I'm just kidding. The microone jokes are good. >> I did
have a fear of
>> It's still hard for me to look at him.
>> Here we go. >> Tech, don't you look at all day?
Isn't like your job? You basically look at all the time. Half
your [__] as you talk about is
you are you love you talk about sex all the time. YOU REFER TO
YOURSELF AS A WHITE LUCARI WHO literally is addicted to porn.
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT THAT you're afraid of?
>> he absolutely is. He absolutely is like a addict or
has talked about basically being a addict and all the time, right?
He just made a tweet about it recently. That was his Lucari tweet.
No, was you got to you got to watch the prediction, guys. That'll
get you. That'll jump up and get you.
>> I'm a straight man, but something about them. JUST JUST
>> JESUS. I've got Miz on 40% volume. I usually have my
my Chrome window turned way higher than this all the time. I've
got him on like 40% volume. It's too >> So, you know, SEX
ALL THE TIME. YOU REFERRED TO YOURSELF AS A WHITE LUCARI who
literally is addicted to the porn. What are you talking about?
>> This does apply to something else. Give it a second.
Give it a second. Give it a second. This is going to be This
is also Teetone's reaction when he thinks about the fact that
Mskiff got to be with
>> Thank you, Msk. Thank you. Thank you. >> And so,
you know,
you know, when I lost my virginity, I had to even close my eyes
just to kind of go through the
Sorry, bro. He is so gay. He is actually gay. Msk, if you got
the hater energy within your spirit, okay? If you've got it within
your soul, call this man gay right now. Call him gay
right now, okay? There is no other option. >> AM I RAMBLING?
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH ME?
SO, the first time that you broke up, >> dude. No. Wait.
Wait. I thought he MADE THAT UP. I THOUGHT HE I thought he ad
lipped that. I thought he had lip down. It's actually in the
transcript. Sorry. Am I rambling? What was the exact question,
dude?
They didn't work on this. This, by the way, this is how it should
work with your lawyer. You are going to go over, you are going
to actually rehearse and practice your direct examine because
it opens up holes. If you say, it opens up holes in cross that
you can get on, which I know as much as Teto might like that,
probably in court, you shouldn't be trying to open yourself up
for that. Okay. Holy [__] There's no way that you
should. Sorry. Am I rambling? What was the exact question? So
that was the first time you broke up,
>> Can we get back to that techn
are you on about? Yes. >> There's no way. >> Okay.
Sorry. Okay. Yeah. There was this one time where she didn't
even get John. Yes. Hold on. Yes. So, the first time that you
broke up, did you break up with her or the first time?
Sorry. Did she Did she break up with you or was it mutual? Oh,
no.
Yeah. Though the first time we broke up, I knew I had to do it.
Give me a sec. So, my friend said, "You know, you're not dating
a girl at this point. YOU'RE DATING A MONSTER."
BECAUSE THEY KNEW HOW pink was back in the day because they
judge. I'm going to object to hearsay and move on to strike.
Sustained.
Did I Did I say something wrong?
You can't say something that someone else said. Sorry. Yeah.
Absolutely, sir.
Oh, sorry. Yeah. So, did you break up with her? Yes. Or did she
break up with you or was it mutual? It was >> All of my
All my friends said this was
>> We went to the closet and we sat down on the floor and
I initiated the breakup. John, yes. Did you break up with her
or did she break up with you? I broke up. Or was it mutual? I
believe it was mutual. Okay. The first time? Yes. Okay. Let's
talk about the second time. Sure. Are you kidding me? Techone.
What the is this? What are you saying?
What are you saying? The second time you broke up? Did she break
up with you? She Did you break up with her or is it mutual? She
broke up with me. Okay. So literally, Teone straight up just
tried to lie in court and then he just got he just admitted the
truth finally after five pages of going through this that it
was mutual and then the second time she broke up with him. Holy
[__] That took
No, you have to understand
he just couldn't. He was just too scared of
Listen, even there Miz Miz, even there he literally had a trauma
response. He started rambling about nothing. Okay, he he entered
He was being covered in crabs again in his mind. Okay, he could
see the crabs. Schizophrenia assist on this one. Okay, he could
see the crabs once again. He was totally up. He just started
rambling about how much he hates until the warrior was like,
"Wait, wait.
So that's why you broke up?" Wait, what was the question? I just
hate Oh my god. When I think of him, I just start seeing down
into this deep dark pit. Sarlac pit from Star Wars. Techone.
Wait, what? What?
Where am I? Where am I? Where am >> Jesus Christ.
That was insanity.
>> What the [__] That took forever for him
to [__] admit that [__] Jesus
>> And that's the the time
uh strike that. It's fair to say that after you broke up, you
continued to communicate. Yep. Okay. Is it fair to say that after
you broke up, you continued being intimate with each other? Yep.
Okay. Is it fair to say that after you broke up, you remained
friends? I tried it best I could, but I'm sorry. Okay. Were things
cordial? Yeah, totally, dude. Okay. Cordial yet a little bit
uncomfortable as um anybody who breaks up with someone would
be. Sure. Complicated? Yeah. You guys have been together for
a year and a half. And I'm not going to lie, I was um shortly
after we broke up,
I did become interested in a another >> Dude, this gift
could go out for um for like shownen dubs. He's at least as good
as any like shownen dub actor like voice actor. He could totally
do it. Yeah. Hold on. Where was it? Where's the line?
Oh, I'm not going to lie. I was uh shortly after we broke up
did become interested in another girl. In another girl. I can't
dude. I can't even do it. He does. He can do like the the western
VA for animes. He Misk is doing the voice. That's the reason
I'll never watch a dub in my entire life is all I can say. All
right. Dub watchers out. >> Oh, no. That's not what I wanted.
>> There. But you continue. >> Wait, what is he?
>> Um, and I'm not going to lie, I was shortly after we
broke up, I I did become interested in another girl.
>> Okay. And so, you know, it it made things a little complicated
just all these women throwing themselves at me. Okay. And but
you continued communicating with each other almost every day.
Dude, why is he getting so off topic with this? Like what the
Yes. Okay. She was living with there at the house. There was
there was talk for us to continue moving in to a new place together
because our uh that's evidence that Miz has literally never watched
the Techone stream.
Teone Nicholas Dioro
brothers basically. Okay. These guys can't stay on top. residents,
for lack of a better term, just kind of suck, dude. Okay, so
we were going to a new place all together as friends, but kind
of foresaw that wasn't going to be possible if I wanted to have
a new partner. So, me being, you know, 30, 31, I I don't really
have too much time to waste to my eyes. So, we decided to not
or more so I decided that we should not live together. Okay.
And she moved out. Yes. Was this before or after after Austin
Oaks? To the best of my knowledge, I believe it was shortly after.
Yep. Yep. No, it was shortly after Austin Oaks, her assistant
helped her move out.
I want to ask you about I want to fast forward to November 20th,
I Dude, I
I'm trying to think of like
Oh, I'm trying to think in my head
where they're even go what what has been the point of this direct
examination?
What have they even established? Just techone getting on the
record. No, I
I don't know what else they're even trying to like normally for
when Pink's lawyer was direct examining her. I could tell what
she was setting up, I could see the direction. It was very obvious,
right? I don't know what this guy's trying to do. Like, what
are you trying to set up here? I thought 24.
>> When did you first find out about Pink's tweet? Um,
I found about her probably before it was even posted. I heard
ramblings from some of my friends that someone was going to be
posted. I'm going to object to hearsay. sustained and again John
you can't say what someone else told you sorry
were you made aware of yes the tweet at some point yes okay >> were
you aware of yes
>> very quickly after the posting >> the court >> how
quickly >> the court the court reporter couldn't just let
that one go to him over on that one too make him look like a
Were you made aware of yes I was I'm aware of all >> almost
instantly dude okay uh so the tweet tweet was on November 20th,
2024. Did you find out about it on November 20th, 2024?
Yeah, dude. I saw it after it was posted and it was it was so
much to take in and then Yeah, that is when I found out about
it or at least when I saw it. Okay. Did you start receiving messages
online about that? So
now on direct or sorry on cross now it's going to be like okay
but actually in June or July I believe July because I believe
is the day before she went to
the the place the hospital
he has that conversation about her telling a friend that tee
forced her to give right
so he can't say that he's like unaware but he's it's like they're
trying to paint it as he was unaware and like very shocked by
it. >> That tweet, dude, so fast, man. The the heads of
my company told me I'm going to be objection to hearsay sustained.
John, listen to the question I'm asking. Sorry. That >> this
is a disaster. >> Did you receive messages? Yes. About
Pink's tweet?
Yes. Okay. Very good, honey. Very good.
She did it a lot of to my ex. And so then I saw this and oh god,
it's happening to me, John. it. Well, it it it's well known that
to your followers that you were dating Pink. Oh, it was blatantly
obvious, dude. Okay. Would you When you say it was blatantly
obvious, what do you mean? I mean, she would >> just say
yes.
>> As random characters, you know, we would stream together,
I would be on like every single one of her streams, you know,
when she would have an anxiety attack, I'd be like, "You good,
dude? We'll take care of the stream. Everything's going to be
okay." It was It was pretty much as clear as mud. >> Yeah.
Hold on. Clear as day. What do you mean clear as mud? That means
it's not
Hey, Tyone.
This isn't your stream, Rock. Just going to let the things you
say go. Okay. How about you
stop trying to I don't know, monologue on everything. Just say
yes when the guy asked the question. Could you just Yeah. Absolutely
dented behavior like this guy's got this guy got kicked in the
head by a horse or
What the are we doing?
Like what? What are you talking about? >> Is that a saying?
>> That is a saying because clear as day, clear as like
clear as anything. Clear as clear as day is the good is the one
I use. But that means it's crystal clear. It's very obvious.
Clear as mud means the opposite. It means it's incredibly difficult
to tell. It's not clear at all. You use it like sarcastically.
Well, that's clear as mud. Thank you for clarifying that. Clear
as mud now, right? Buddy and the waters all tying to the same
thing. >> Is that a phrase?
>> It means the opposite. >> I'm gonna Is that a
phrase that's ever used? Is the phrase clear as mud ever >> Yes.
Yes.
>> Clear as mud. >> Not at all. Easy to understand.
>> When someone says something is >> not at all easy
to understand as in he's trying to say it's easy to understand.
>> Clear. They mean it's confusing, poorly explained, or
not clear at all. Okay. So, I guess it's real.
Wait,
but that doesn't make sense to what he's saying.
But he used >> the opposite. He used the opposite way.
>> I would be like, "Are you okay?" Like, "Wait, so he
basically said
was not clear at all to everything he just talked about." >> One
thing we could say for sure is Tech >> conflict resolution
god. >> Maybe he just meant when he said that, maybe he
just meant he can't do conflict resolution at all. Maybe that's
what he meant. Like I'm actually terrible at conflict resolution,
man. This guy's just a >> I mean, she would dress up as
random characters, you know, we would stream together. I would
be on like every single one of her streams, you know, when she
would have an anxiety attack, I'd be like, "Are you okay?" Like,
"We'll take care of the stream. Everything's going to be okay."
It was it was pretty much as clear as mud
for anybody to see. And it literally is the when people say clear
as mud, it's confusing. So, he's saying it's confusing to anyone
that we were dating.
What an idiot, dude. What an idiot. By the way,
was it well known to your followers that you were dating Pink?
Yes.
That's that's how you handle this. Basically, I think if I'm
not mistaken, when you're under direct, like unless you're being
asked to like uh qualify something, it should be mostly yes or
no answers. It feels like, right?
Yeah. John, were you were your followers aware you were dating
Pink? Yep.
If they want to ask you how, then you can go into that. But that's
the whole point. if if the other if the other attorney wants
to ask you how that's something she can peel back.
But yeah, he just talks to this. He's just like a amazing.
And then look
look his his lawyer tries to stop him and go, "Okay, like stop
honey." And he goes for anybody to see. Okay. It was well known
to her followers she was dating you. It was well known to your
followers that you were dating her. Is that I would like to clarify
for all fairness. It was very clear to my followers. To her followers,
maybe not so much. But to mine, yes. Very apparent, dude. Okay.
And did your followers knew? No. When the relationship had run
its course? Yeah, bro. Okay. So, again, when you saw this tweet,
did you have any doubt that she was talking about you? No. There
was not a single doubt in my mind. All right. And then in that
vein, now we're talking about respondence number.
>> I feel like there should have been some doubts. No.
When you said there's not a single doubt in your mind, did you
insult her? No. Then why didn't you doubt that it was about you
would be my first question coming up to ask you questions like
what? Shouldn't you have like not at all had any idea what she
was talking about? Shouldn't you been like, "Wow,
her previous boyfriend must have been."
Number five, you start to get to where the messages adds almost
as soon as Pink's tweet went up. Yes. and his respondents. Five,
an accurate characterization of the types of messages you would
receive. I'm assuming that this is something that's probably
saying like, "Fuck you. You insulted her or you're a bad person."
They were way worse than that. There's one's more of a, you know,
like a get on post, but yeah, that was a lot worse than that.
Okay. And are there respondents 67 and we see in respondents
>> Is this like are people doing this intentionally everywhere
now? How does this keep happening?
>> It's just everywhere. # techone. Yep. With a post date.
It looks like the November of 21st. Yep. That one of the one
of previous that was before the hashtag from techone to # redone
is my new name on the internet instantaneously.
Yes. Being called a was very frequent. And on respondents exhibit
six, it looks like looks like underneath your shirt there's a
2M. What does the represent?
2M means 2 million views. Okay. So this post there was a 2 million
views. Yes. Okay. Looking at respondents exhibit 8. This was
posted on 10:49 a.m. on November 21st. And how many views did
it have that has um 37,000 views, which is one of the smaller
ones. >> Um then this is Pink's lawyer comes in says, "Judge,
the only thing I'd like to point out is there's no identication
of when these pictures were taken. These screenshots to know
at any time on November 21st when there were actually that many
views. So I don't think that the court agrees, which I would
say is very fair. How would you know that? I think there's a
mischaracterization of the evidence before the court. I think
that goes to the weight, not necessarily the admissability.
Correct. And let's talk about respondent exhibit 9. Let's talk
about that. How many
like there is some of that, right? That
uh how would this go? If this were like about calculating damages,
I could see this being a much more important conversation.
I don't know if it's like a terribly important conversation right
now. It's about I guess
like I'm trying to think of how this would relate to the stalking
and assault claims, right? Like it could be something that's
relevant to other cases. I'm trying to think of like here
she's trying to argue that
maybe that this guy's responses over like it's outweighs anything
she's done. So she's trying to say, "Well, no, I didn't even
I didn't even really draw that much attention to this until he
did." I guess that means a little bit to me. It's like I
this doesn't feel like it's super
it's not really making the case that you didn't assault somebody.
It's not making the case that you are having like healthy and
and like like wellfounded responses to what she's saying. It's
just like oh it's basically trying to argue how much she deserves
the uh the rhetoric you're spewing. >> How many views did
it have? That had um 2.1 million views. Okay. And that was posted
when before I responded. So that was about I think I responded
at like 5:00 a.m. or some that was like 26 hours before then.
Okay. So almost immediately afterwards maybe like what 12 hours
after Pink posted and I want to there's been some some questions
from the applicant about the timing of these views of course
and when the traffic happened when eyes were on Yeah. the allegations
against you from pink. Was it that they were use seeing in respondents
for exhibit 10?
Well, there's a great one because this shows you exactly how
many live people were watching the day of the 21st. As you can
see on the bottom there, it says noon techone salt allegations.
And as you could tell, the viewer count, judging by the green
graph, is going up. If you notice, the peak is at 12:00 to 12:50,
which is when denims uh changed >> dude, I SOMEHOW just
knew denims are going to brought get brought up somewhere here.
This is what I was talking about earlier, right? It's literally
Teetone is going to take everybody else using Pink talking about
like something that happened to her, venting about something
that happened to her and they're going to call Techone a with
that and he is going to see that as Pink causing everybody to
call him a He won't be able to see it any other way. It's not
going to be like people disingenuously framing things against
him. It's not going to be anything like that. It will just be
all her fault forever no matter what.
It's just like Denims is in this guy's head all the time. Forever
no matter what. their stream title to the tech tone sexual >> which
you know it ended up not being disingenuous but I I do think
that even if even if it weren't like a wellfounded allegation
it didn't matter Denims didn't necessarily know a whole lot about
it she was still going to go with this stuff right
and yeah it is going to blow up and and people are going to use
it against you but again how much of that is on Pink versus other
people on the internet
like she has a right to talk about things that have happened
to her and she did I guess not name I don't know, one of those
things, man. >> And her, amongst many other streamers were
all live streaming that, including Mike from PA from a previous
screenshot and leveraging viewers to come in and react to it
live on the 21st. I even had a chance to say anything.
And what do we see on the second page of respon? >> Dude,
this is so telling. This is just so telling. Again, by the way,
I'll remind you this is about whether or not he's been stalking
Pink, whether or not he's insulted Pink, right? And they're choosing
to spend their time complaining about denims
and Mike from PA. That's what they're spending their time doing,
right?
Like it's it's crazy.
Bonnets 10. Yep. That's another stream where the real lifetime
viewers are there. It was a 4hour stream and you could tell the
moment that techone saw allegations is going to be covered that
yellow font is the indication that the stream title changed to
that bro. And you could tell the interest is at the alltime high
for that individual stream which is dun dun denims who is in
top 500 streamers in the entire world out of I believe like 700
billion people.
Okay. So is it fair to say that when you respond on November
22nd, 2024 to the false allegations that Pink had made in her
tweet, is it fair to say that there has been was a substantial
amount of understanding and knowledge about the accusations against
you? Not only was there substantial knowledge for anybody who's
a Twitter savvy genius like myself, it was also trending on Twitter
in the United States. So yeah, dude, everyone was
again,
that's not really a function of pink. I I swear that's not really
a function of pink as much as so many other people would have
had like a nuanced take on that if you weren't the most hated
on this right-wing griff. like he was already starting to get
towards it, right? He had already done all the fighting with
Denims and Hassan's whole group,
right? He was in the middle of fighting with these people. That's
why they were covering it because you had internet beefs with
them. You were talking about what a Denims is. You were talking
about how fat Frogan is, right? I'm almost positive this was
before this stuff dropped. So like
it just seems really clear to me
that you are blaming pink for those people's responses when those
people would have taken anything against you. They would have
talked about you no matter what.
And he's blaming it all in pink. And by the way, this is about
again whether or not he assaulted her and whether or not he was
stalking her. You can't use other people's actions as a basis
for why you're okay to do that or why it's like awesome for you
to do that >> about it. which is why it forced me to respond
as well as the owners of my company decided to let me go as well
because of the allegations.
I thought Teto was let go because
he said that it was because he his contract was up. That's what
he told everybody.
Was it was Pink? >> He actually did say that as well as
the owners of my company decided to let me go as well. Oh
yeah, fantastic point, Msk.
He's told everybody forever that he wasn't let go from OTK, that
he was um that he his contract was up. I mean, we didn't believe
him. We knew that this was wrong,
We knew this was a lie. We all pointed it out that no, they just
let you leave. They let you say you were leaving. That was their
nice sendoff for you. And here it is in 4K. Him saying himself
under oath. Yeah, I was fine. create a secret or in small sphere
of knowledge or influence when you responded
already.
>> It went viral quickly as well as the multiple articles
as well as multiple Twitter accounts that were covering it due
to those to Pink's benefit. This is her alternate account, but
an alternate account does not prevent a tweet from going viral,
dude. And that tweet very much went viral and the internet ran
with it. Okay. So, on November 21st, did you receive news about
your future employment for your prospects with part one of your
businesses? Yes. Okay. And what was that? OTK decided they had
to let me go. They had two previous members, one of them being
Rich who said allegations did not get proven his innocence until
three years after as well as another streamer by the name of
Misg who also had assault allegations and he is still kind of
up in the air.
Mama I made it to Forbes. So people were already to run with
the ball of look at that another streamer from this or is a piece
of and you were let go. I'm gonna say this. It wasn't just the
fact that he was an OTK that people were saying that. It was
also because of Frame previously and all that drama that happened
that people were believing that
>> It's no man. It's literally the like how hard he was
going after Frogan and the entire Hassan sphere was just like
psyched to be able to just cut this guy down, right? I think
that's what caused it. That's why he names Denims and Mike from
PA cuz they were just psyched to take this guy down a bit that
this guy had something come out that they could go after him
for,
right? like they hated him and a lot of people were starting
to dislike this guy already at this point. I do think so. I think
there's something to that pivot, that like leftwing pivot or
whatever. There's something to it, but it's not the entire story.
He was starting on this before the allegations came out against
him. I'm almost thinking he started on it the second he realized
the allegations were going to be coming out. >> Do this.
It wasn't just uh the fact that it was OTK. It was very much
that that one video that was going around where F was basically
sitting in the car while Tekken was bragging about how good he
is to his wife. I did not want to play >> Look good. You've
been losing weight. Do I look different than when I first started
camp?
>> Because I'm bald. >> Cuz your face
>> abusive relationship. >> Mhm. That's why I'm leaving.
>> Okay. I don't like this joke anymore.
I don't like this joke. Frig, I'll give you a hug.
She's leaning away from him. >> Have a hug back. The pat
on the back feels very fathersonish.
>> Thank you. >> Welcome. You made a great day. Good.
Good. Good.
>> If you want to do something, let me know. Okay.
>> I can't. >> Why would you just play? >> Yeah.
All right.
Yeah, the car clip. If anyone wants to find that, let me and
we will watch it on the the stream. We can do that. All right.
So people were ready to run the
instantly. I have to say much to OTK's benefit. They were very
sweet dude. >> It was Asmin, dude. He's just such a sweet
guy. They were put out a statement because they just wanted to
move past. They said, "Thank you, Techone, for being part of
us. We will not renew your contract." And I echoed the same in
sentiments. I said, "Yep, I enjoy my time. We departed, bro."
Okay. But OTK was So he tried to talk about OTK and his lawyer
stopped him and was like the next Okay, ready the car clip.
How do I deal with him? I love him.
>> Don't touch. >> I'm patient.
>> No, you're [__] not.
>> You're like the most impatient,
>> dude. It's just so rough.
>> It's just so rough, man.
>> I carry our marriage and you know that.
>> That's such a random thing to bring up about being impatient
and then go to
>> Free, you know that. >> I think we have a pretty
1550.
You know
>> You're high. >> You're kidding.
>> On stream. Is this content or Wait, you're kidding,
bro.
>> You think you think so? >> You think I help? >> I'm
not saying you don't help, but you think you think it's 50/50.
>> Ever heard him, mate? >> M is eating a lot. He's
bulking. Okay,
let a man bulk in peace. The
>> explain explain. >> I mean, okay. >> I would
unironically say I'm probably one of the best husbands on planet
>> You're a very good husband. >> No, no, I wouldn't
say very good. I would say one of the best. I would say I'm goated
with the sauce. >> Okay. I'm just saying like you carry
in social aspects. I carry in the back of tech stuff. And I feel
like together we make a good team. >> No, wait. I don't
want marriage.
>> Marriage. Not not tech stuff. >> I mean, our marriage,
>> backend tech stuff, like
setting up the ring cameras, >> our our business relationship
with me helping with your career
>> cuz that's a big part of our marriage. Subathon is a
big part of our marriage. >> I'm saying I'm saying take
a job out. Take jobs out.
Sure, you help me with tech stuff for my career. Sure. But marriage,
dude, I am the conflict resolution god. IS THAT YOUR >> LET'S
GO. THAT'S the clip. We love that. We love it. It's our favorite.
It's our
>> My goodness. Also, I might have to start skipping clips,
dude. We've got so much left to cover and I don't know if I could
I don't know if I can stay up late enough to do it. I probably
can,
>> I do want to finish the whole transcript here, but Jesus.
>> Greatest shoulder to cry on. I am the greatest consoler.
>> He's also the most humble >> understanding everything.
The romantic [__] I do is crazy. >> Bro, is
there anything more appropriate than him wearing like the the
Trump boomer shades while saying the romantic I do is crazy when
he's never eaten box in his entire life. Get the out of here,
Teto. Get the out of here. Get the out of here. >> Wait,
are you I'm Why are you giggling?
>> I get that clip. I don't I used to have a streamable
with this clip. I've got it downloaded somewhere. I'm not going
to go find it right now. >> Why are you >> You can
find it though pretty easily. >> Just out there. It's out
there. It's all over the place. >> So Freeman is like not
even being mean here or arguing. She's just kind of like disassociating
and chilling out and he's still going after two and a half
>> Oh, they're okay. Superman.
>> Oh, it gets worse. Oh, he's he's watched this before.
It gets so much worse in the same clip. >> You know, beyond
a shadow of I incredible husband. >> You're I I never said
that you weren't. >> But you never said that I was. >> Okay.
You are an incredible husband. >> I agree. I am so understanding.
>> Dude, this guy sets up all his own compliments and everything.
Uh, tell me how great a husband I am. You are a great husband.
Now tell me you want to suck my dick. Dude,
uh, listen, if you don't say the things he wants, he'll tell
you to say the things he wants. Okay? This guy never fails to
get what he wants. >> All of your wants and needs.
All of them. I know how accommodating I've been in.
It's not enough for him to just say all these things to totally
like break you down and then just be like, "Hey, I'm the best."
Yeah, you are. Say, "I'm the best. You're good." No. Say, "Teone,
you are the best. Techone, you are the conflict resolution god."
And then tell me that you want to suck my dick. Like, dude, are
you okay? Are you are you good? Did you read a room ever in your
entire life? >> It's one thing to not even have chat. It's
another thing to never even pleasure them, you know? It's it's
it's it's it just shows that you are selfish as and you're not
you're a piece of like to if a woman desires pleasure and wants
pleasure and you're not providing that at all like even like
not only through
>> don't look like a normal person miskif desire do you
desire pleasure desire pleasure can you just talk like a normal
person I understand this is a weird >> also demanding oral
compensation it's like what the [__] Is that >> Bro,
I I know what he's doing. He doesn't want to sound cringe talking
about, so he's like trying to use more like
noble terms. >> You're scary, bro. Have you ever been with
a girl? Have you ever been with a
>> Nothing gayer than eating box, bro. >> Are are
you kidding me? Do you think that women don't want to be satisfied
as well? Do you think women just want to please men and like
feed them grapes while they drop off their >> Yes. Exactly.
Yes. >> Do you think that's how it works?
oral compensation >> girls have cooties. Yeah, I'm sure
Teone says that in like page 179. We'll get to >> I'm saying
Mhm.
>> Yes, I agree. Uh-uh.
Of course. >> So, we're like marriages and emotions and
understanding and communication.
I would say I do about 90% of that.
>> dude. Look at the look at the nervous ticks from her.
Look at her like peel her face. No wonder he thinks people's
faces are melting. This is like the reaction that most people
get. She's like pinching herself and like pulling her face down
right here. >> She just like can't handle this guy. >> I
would say I do about 90% of that >> right there. She's
like literally just pinking her dude. She's like am I am I dreaming?
Is this guy out of his mind? Am I having a nightmare? Wake up.
Wake up. Wake up. Wake up. Wake up. Wake up. Wake up. Wake up.
Wake up.
>> Okay, there we go. Then the majority of marriage is
communication.
>> She's like she's like the female Vosch, but she doesn't
have a beard. She's just pulling on her face.
>> That's like the Bosch dick. One to one, but she's just
pulling on her face instead of her beard.
>> I'm just saying, dude. When it comes to emotions, dealing
with our issues and >> Okay. When it comes to emotions
and dealing with our issues, yes, you are
>> But I'm looking at aole. Like, you help me out, I help
you out. >> THIS GUY SUCKS. UH,
>> I give you your space, you give me my space. We mutually
love each other. We mutually are happy with each other versus
each other as a friend. I hope. >> It's a lot of assuming
happening right
>> It's a lot of assuming. I would say you're a GOAT HELPER.
>> DUDE, WHAT THE did you just hand her your glasses for?
He's just like >> in the middle of talking, he takes his
glasses off and he just like >> folds them and just holds
them out for her to have.
>> Like while he's doing this, he's just Bro, that is like
a weird dominance move for no reason.
Yes, it is like a form of control. I'm doing this on stream.
You have to take these now. I control you. I control you. You
take these from me on stream or turn this into a bigger fight
on stream right now. I dare you.
No, >> I would say you're a goated helper. >> You're
a goated helper.
>> I was just >> Now she's disassociated completely
after Techone said that it made her feel like >> Yeah,
goated helper. >> Now she is about to just like totally
She basically just like wants to fight to stop. Wants him to
stop talking. >> Wait, why you being weird?
>> Not a goated wife.
I'm talking about the specifics. >> Oh, okay. >> Right.
Like we talking about like I'm the communication guy, right?
Like the communication guy, but I feel like >> she starts
picking out her face because she's uncomfortable and feels that
this is an attack and she's trying to disassociate by picking
out her face. >> You as a helper is very good. You keep
[__] on track.
I'm learning. >> Dude, he honestly wants her to be thankful
for the tantrum he's throwing. Like he thinks this is communication.
He thinks the tantrum he's throwing is communication that he
is expressing like how the relationship works and how they communicate
and how they're like going to fix things, how it's all good and
he's got it and but he's actually just throwing a tantrum and
like on her and he wants her to be thankful for on her like he
is correcting her and you should be thankful for that. Why aren't
you talking about how great I am while I on
>> for how do I >> No, this clip made the rounds.
No, no, no, J. This clip 100% made the rounds because he came
up with an entire lie just to explain this clip to people. Say
70,000 views on this clip. He came up with an entire lie. Also,
>> well, if um somebody attacked me, then there's not really
any reason to attack
>> Somebody isn't attacking me, then there isn't really
a reason to attack them. Okay. Self-defense.
Self-defense. So many overlaps internet
>> Did all that change on November 20th,
>> Yes, dude. the Fire Nation attacked. Okay. Would you
receive messages threatening you? Oh, yeah. Okay. Yeah. Would
you receive dozens? Would you receive hundreds? Would you receive
thousands? I know it's kind of hard for someone who's not plugged
in to quantify this, dude. But tens of thousands
daily. Not just messages, but you know, messages to my face on
like my stream as well as people in my real life many of times.
Thankfully, I'm a bigger guy, so I was able to feel a little
bit safe. And I did admittedly just stop going out for a while.
But yes, those messages were constant. And to be honest, they
still are. Okay. You still receive threats? Yeah. Threatening
your life? Yes. I've even been swatted on attempts of me. Oh,
was he actually swatted?
Uh, I want to say we determined that this was fake. Unless you
think swatting is just the police coming to your house. If you
think getting a visit from police is swatting, you're a Okay,
swatting is a very specific thing with a very specific definition
with very specific requirements. If you think getting a wellness
check from the cops like, "Hey, we heard something bad happened
here." If you think that's sweating, you are a >> as well.
Okay. Somehow someone somehow got my address. I don't know how.
And they told me I had children upstairs and I was them. And
so,
judge, I'm going to object as hearsay. The court sustained. Detective
just keeps going on tangents. Thank you. Do you still receive
threats? Yes. About your life? Yes. Okay. For the last five months,
have you had any firearms in the house? No, sir. Can you protect
yourself? No, sir. Okay. Do you continue to receive threats from
people online? By the hour. On the hour. Every time Assan finally
Have you called Pink since the application for a protective order
was filled? No, sir. Have you emailed Pink? No, sir. No, sir.
>> Have you messaged Pink in any way? No, >> I wish.
I mean, no, sir. On any social media channels? No sir. >> Have
you direct messaged her? No sir. Have you sent her a letter?
No sir. Have you gone by her house? No, I don't have any plans
to. In fact, did you move? I moved. Yes. Just to get away from
everything. I moved to San Antonio in Pacific's Fair Oaks. Okay.
Which is about 2 hours away. Have you attempted to contact her
in any way? Nope. And since that application for a protective
order was filled, have you discussed the situation with specifically
have you used her name? Have I used your name in specifically
in recent memory or like what was the time period? Great, dude.
Well, let me put it this way. Yep. Pink made an allegation towards
you. Yes. From your perspective, that tweet was about you and
accuse you of those things that are in the tweet. Oh, yeah. Is
that fair? Yeah. Did you defend your innocence? Of course.
And did you actually make statements online that were the truth
would come out? Absolutely. Of course. Okay. Did you ever threaten
Pink with any kind of physical violence? No, dude. I'll pass
the witness, your honor. All right. Thank you, Miss >> Okay.
This should be
Sorry. This should be very funny. This is the cross coming up
from Pink's lawyer. Okay. And I just spotted the first question.
Mr. Robertson, Mr. Robertson,
did you ever engage in intercourse with my client?
Is that I feel like that's crazy. That's like a crazy That's
a once in a-lifetime question to ask. Did you engage in vaginally?
Knowing what the answer is. Knowing the answer is no ma'am. No
ma'am. No ma'am. No.
Gross. Don't you know?
Gross. >> Thank you. Here it comes. Chat the
of Teone VERSUS
>> OH NO, THE NEXT QUESTION.
SIR, SIR,
have you ever eaten the box?
No, ma'am.
Have you ever engaged in intercourse with my client? No, ma'am.
>> Have you ever eaten my client's box?
>> No, ma'am. No, I have not. >> Pink chew. This
is now Pink Chu's lawyer going after Tee
all that is. So, as of this moment, Tech is denying basically
that he ever talked to her. Teone said some really pathetic things.
Teone really was horrible on the stand and did a absolutely terrible
job. He just wouldn't answer the questions. He was constantly
going off
>> like, okay, that almost fails to capture it. Basically,
what what examinations are is you get your lawyers coming up
and he's examining you, right? It's a direct examination. You
can rehearse that as much as you want. There is no acceptable
reason on planet Earth for you as a millionaire to totally up
your direct examination and fail to answer questions directly
and make it take a bunch of time and talk in circles about random
[__] nobody cares about. There is no excuse on planet
Earth for that. And it was the entirety of the direct
It's actually [__] ludicrous. Why are you talking
about uh it it was it was baffling. Okay. It Msk despite Msk
saying it was a disaster. He has failed to truly capture just
how bad it was. It was cataclysmic. >> Tangent. Uh he admitted
that he wouldn't have with them. He admitted that scare them.
Um he admitted it's because he was raped when he was a child.
Um, he >> assaulted when he was a child. >> Let's
see what else it was. It was
>> I believe grinding would be salt. There was no >> He
went and said, "Look, um, I always have appreciated Pingchu.
I still care about her basically and I want the best for her
and I just want this to be over with. It's just a bunch of baloney.
I mean, he's just trying to soften the because he is scared of
what's about to come with this."
Um, so and that was the part that was supposed to make him look
good. Keep in mind that was his lawyer talking to him, right?
So that's their course of action they planned with four other
lawyers. That was their course of action. It's basically just
saying, "I haven't really talked to her. >> I'm sure his
lawyers begged him to settle." Well, I don't even think you settle
You don't settle this case. >> You don't you don't settle
this. You um
I mean, maybe you could argue there's some kind of private settlement
for her to withdraw the the civil suit. I guess maybe you could
settle. I guess I technically you could probably settle anything
in a civil matter, but like this is this isn't her suing for
money. She gets her lawyer's fees back, but this isn't her really
suing for money. This is just her like basically filing an application
with the state and then there's a hearing on it, right? >> I'm
scared of a because I was raped when I was a kid and um I am
6'7 and um dude, like I I love mythic talent.
>> Also, he did say that he's very scared about losing
his guns. which I think is actually an important thing to include
that he gets threats and he's very scared to not have his guns.
You're in
67. 67. Yes, we keep saying the height.
Uh
why couldn't they have just said he was 66 or 68? Why' they have
to say 67?
Anyway, um
oh uh he's very scared to not have guns when he's getting threats
online. I do think that's like a relevant piece of defense for
taking into account just how widespective
order should be
and they totally disregard that in the end as we obviously know
already. We kind of know the conclusion on this. But it is interesting
that he laid that out there that I I'm scared to be without my
weapons because I feel like I might have to defend myself and
they're like, "Yeah, we don't care." >> All right, >> we
don't care. We don't care. >> Let's see. And he he was
speeding in a 65 to an 80 to go protect her from a cockroach.
And when they got pulled over said it's all good
story as they basically let a police escort to her house where
he jumped out, ran through the wall, grabbed her by the grabbed
her, pulled her to safety, and brought her all the way back home
and was saved her for the rest of his life. Amen. And everyone
clapped. Yes, Tone did it for a cockroach. He's He's a >> Everybody
clapped. Oh my god. Tecton's like a hero.
>> He's like a hero. >> Mr. Robertson.
This is now Pink's lawyer. This is where this is the This is
the final part, right? 188 out of 225, chat. So, let's see what
she has up her sleeve. All right, let's see if Mischief lied
about things. Let's see if Misk told the truth. >> I knew
I knew I had that soundbite >> Mis said a lot of things.
Let's see if Misk was lying. All right,
so as of right now in we're at page 188, who do you think's got
this in the bag? I'll be honest with you because I don't know
the ending. Right.
>> No, we do know the ending. And also, Teone has not even
made any case for himself. Tech's literally made no case except
this is crazy.
And I'm really scared of this is crazy and I'm terrified of that's
that's his case so far. Okay, >> guys. It's already looking
like um Techone in my opinion is looking way worse because Pink
uh I think Pink's case makes a lot more sense and she clearly
had a lot more evidence to prove that Pink was getting harassed
even after the protective order and after that she called a cease
and desist. Um, and I don't think they really had any severe
evidence other than the fact that she was messaging him
um or she messaged him something and that uh she >> but
the circumstances by which that message came about are insane.
>> Didn't it took her 14 months to finally go to the police,
right? Um but >> which is explained by the fact that the
literally the coercive stuff wasn't happening until two years
into the relationship, right? Or a year and 3 months into the
relationship or >> It's it's not the best argument. I think
right now it's 50/50 or like maybe 6040 her. I don't really think
it's like a big win >> in terms of like the protective
order and all the stuff going on here. I think the fact that
his lawyer presented that that text as if it was like absolving
in some way left out all of the context that hurts Teetone massively,
right? That looks really bad. And then I think given how bad
his direct examination is and how he doesn't really speak to
the allegations outside of saying they're not true, he says they're
not true and then they really don't add anything else and he
rambles and he looks nervous and I think all of that looks bad
to the judge. I would say the big the reason why it's now 6040
is Tech was just so bad on the stand and just it's so fake on
how he acted. I don't think he realizes that lawyers can see
through that in judges and it's like dude Tone is so bad. That
was crazy what he said. It's it's really bad. And when I say
64, I mean Tech's still really disgusting and really bad and
they have evidence to prove that with receipts, but is it enough
for Tech to get the the 10 years? No.
All right, let's So let's see. He just he talks way too much.
Notice how when Pink talked, she said, "Yes, no, maybe so, I
don't know." Teone went into massive detail about things that
just didn't matter. And his lawyer had to try to stop him. Okay,
here we go. Well, I think, dude, what could his lawyer even do?
His lawyer did say, "Please listen to the questions I'm asking."
His lawyer did try to stop him. Actually, his lawyer was like,
"Could you just answer the question I asked multiple times?"
>> This is Pinkchu's lawyer against Teong. Why are you
up here? Aren't you a woman? Can't we get like a man up here
or something? Like, what's going on here, guys? No, ma'am. Okay.
And did you ever engage in any Did you ever perform any oral
on my client?
No, ma'am.
So, Tech admits here that he never in his life gave her pleasure
in two years, >> dude. She's actually going to go with
the next question. I can tell where she's going. She's basically
going to go, "Did my client orgasm a single time with you >> of
dating her and she only gave him >> This is legal mindset's
worst nightmare. Okay. His worst nightmare.
He's finding out that his his goat
can't even bring a woman to climax. Okay.
Nothing worse. Nothing worse you could possibly hear for legal
mindset. His goat can't even get a woman off. It's terrible.
>> Every time he asks for two years, he admits it and that's
what his claim is. Not just because are scary. So he said that's
are scary. Why you want Why would you give her oral if if it
like why
>> what I mean if you were to grant him they're scary then
the oral thing follows naturally but >> you reciprocate
anything you did nothing for her because are scary since they're
scary not only will you not them you will not put your finger
near them here we go >> okay did you ever engage in any
did you ever perform oil to my client No. Okay. In fact, the
only one that received any kind of satisfaction was from her.
Is that correct? >> Was you from her? Is that correct?
>> Uh, yes. But she would obviously pleasure herself while
doing this, which
no shot.
No shot.
Uh, yeah. Well, you know, I uh I I didn't pleasure her directly,
sure. But I did allow her to marry me while sucking me off. And
really, doesn't that make me, you know, doesn't that isn't that
me pleasuring her? I'm allowing her to suck my dick while she
met. Is that not Wouldn't women everywhere like line up for the
chance? Come on. Come on,
>> Oh, yeah. Okay. So, in the romantic relationship you
had, would you consider that the only
Yeah. Hold on. Hold on. I missed that. Uh, but she would obviously
pleasure herself while doing this, which dude, I am so upset.
I'm so upset that Pink's lawyer cut him off. What was he going
to say next? Which which
even continue that? But she would obviously believe he was going
to say what I was going to say, which obviously is like me pleasuring
her. She was allowed to She was allowed to get herself off while
sucking my dick. Is that not Am I not a hero for the >> only
person actually getting physical contact from the other partner
to be a normal one? Like what? Oh. >> Oh, hold on. Hold
on. >> I cut his off. >> So, the romantic relationship
you had, would you consider that the only person actually getting
physical contact from the other partner to be a normal one? Like
what you had with her? So, she he literally admits there that
Pingchu would want pleasure herself, but she wouldn't ever get
it. You want a you want a job done right in this house in Te's
house
when the job is a female orgasm? You get that done yourself?
Okay. I want no part of it. >> That's an amazing question
to ask. So, in the romantic relationship you had, would you consider
that the only person actually getting physical contact from the
other partner to be the normal one like the what you had with
her? Unfortunately,
in my mind, it was normal. That's how I my previous relationship
was as well. So, I thought it was just normal.
Teone is trying to claim here in his massive lie that Tecton
is trying to say that he never had or ever pleasured the other
partner even throughout entirety of marrying and dating Free
because he thought it was just normal. When this dude talks about
and content for a living and he says he thought it was just normal
like the biggest lie I've ever heard in my entire life under
oath by the way that he claims is so important as a right-wing
political streamer that being under oath is important to tell
the truth. So help you God, Teone. So help you God, by the way.
Um, and you claim it's under oath. So help you God. The one that
you pretend you care about. Um, that you just lied that you said,
"I thought it was just normal." Tech tone. You literally talk
about all the time on every single one of your Genchin streams
and your
>> I mean,
I think he's saying it's normal as in like I was uh I have this
thing. I don't know if I believe that. I don't think he's saying
he thought other people would think it was normal >> in
general. You talk about how cool it is for how cool you are.
You know what's normal. Everyone knows what's normal. It's [__]
the person. It's having a romantic relationship. You know that's
not normal. My shortcomings are
unfortunate.
>> W music. >> Here we go. Okay. So then this romantic
relationship you had, would you consider that only person actually
getting physical contact from the other person to be a normal
one like what you did with her? It's a good question. And um
unfortunately, dude, in my mind, it it was normal.
That's how my previous relationship was as well.
What was her name again? So, I thought it was just
Bro, can we just get like Can we just pour one out for Frame?
Frame in like a seven-year marriage never got hurt. Not a single
time. Okay. Pour one out for free. That's who the
imagine. Okay. NO,
SHE DEALT WITH THIS FOR SEVEN YEARS.
10 years. Sorry. 10 years.
10 years. Sorry, I'm getting the timeline wrong.
10 years.
Oh, my shortcomings are
unfortunate. >> No, sorry. Um, I do I'm not trying to minimize
what happened to Pig. It's obviously awful. So, just >> I
would have thought years,
But I would admit I was a little selfish
>> Dude, I do think like that's
there is something where like I do think at some point
you are actually
up enough like that you could
like be that you could be demanding to the point where you're
throwing temper tantrums when when the other person isn't pleasuring
you while providing nothing yourself.
That's crazy to me. That's obviously like ridiculous, dude. It's
just It's wild. >> I did, in fact, you not kiss her or
make out with her.
Stop the cap. That's not true. Oh, we kissed quite often. Okay.
Eddie request to spit in her mouth occasionally.
No.
And did you request to spit? No.
I don't believe him. I don't believe him. >> And again,
isn't this like the lady that should be getting the coffee? Like
where's the man who's supposed to be the lawyer for her? Not
like the why is there a woman here? That guy's like okay. And
so is it true that when she said that you did not satisfy her
in any way orally? Correct. That was correct. No, I did not use
my mouth upon her. Nay. Okay. Besides a little smoochy smooch
here and there. And you did not even use your
>> I did not use my >> hands to touch your Isn't
that correct? >> No, they're clean.
You did. Oh, no. I I did not use my hands. Okay. And in fact,
none of like your hands did never go under her pants. Is that
correct? I would grab her butt.
Okay. Over the
>> W miss.
Holy. Under the clothes.
Okay. And that was the extent of it, right? I think the closest,
well, furthest we ever went for me was trying because I did try.
She would wear underwear and I would put my in her and wiggle
it around like lazy town or some like you ever see that stuff?
It's [__] sick, dude. Um, see if I could remain hard.
It just wouldn't work. We tried our best, but it
>> it DID EVERYTHING WORK.
>> SO, it was So, her comments about you having to give
your was accurate. That is truthful, right?
>> I did really APPRECIATE THEM. I APPRECIATE THEM. ALL
RIGHT. I APPRECIATE >> OKAY. AND in fact, on times you
would demand them. Correct.
Nah. No way. I had 2 million subscribers, ma'am. >> Okay.
Isn't it true that you have posted on social media that it's
hot when girls have their lips done with filler for?
Yeah, of course. Duh. Like every guy has. Okay. And in fact,
you said on social media that you can't go too hard on them when
they first get their
>> lip fillers. >> Oh, this guy is he's he's so overconfident.
It's so
>> causes problems with their >> He's about to cook
himself. I know he's going to cook himself with this next
>> It's over.
>> I'm not familiar with the comments, but perhaps I wouldn't
say I didn't say that. Come on. Okay. And in fact, your exact
statement on February 5th of 2025, so after these allegations
were made up, is lip fillers. They do make your lips look, but
the problem is anyone who has lip fillers cannot suck A WORTH
A DAMN. It sucks because if they're suck too hard, it'll fill
up like a balloon on Tuesday on Macy days parade. [__]
their lip fillers. Is that correct? Yeah.
became very familiar with the flaws with
>> he's techone both the lawyer and techone are techone
now. Let's go. >> Techone straight up just admitted what
he did. He straight up admitted right. >> Yeah. Like I
became very familiar with the flaws. Yeah. Exactly. Dude, you
could just tell he's so comfortable. He's going to cook himself.
He is going to say something stupid. I became very familiar with
the flaws with lip filler. Yeah, that's the entire allegation.
Buddy, how did you become so familiar
>> there? Great question. >> What he did?
>> He literally admitted it. Okay. Have you ever also said
online after you were made aware of these allegations by my client
that you are one of the only streamers who has documented a machine?
Pinku Pikachu did
after you were made aware of these allegations by my client that
you are one of the only streamers who has documented a
>> who has had a document machine.
>> Pink you Pikachu did describe her as my sweetie pie
hover hoover machine. Yes, >> Pink did describe herself
as a blow machine. Yes. >> Well, you were actually on your
stream on February 3rd of 2025 actually stating
I'm the only one. I'm sorry. Let me try that again. >> I
am of the only streamers who has had
Is that correct? >> Yes. I was attempted to make light
of the situation.
You're making light of someone accused. Wait, I thought this
was like deeply disturbing because of your commitment to like
because you were assaulted. I thought there was no joking about
this. It was not funny. It was not okay. And you're making light
of someone accusing you of assault. So, you have alleged assault.
Yeah, because the president does it. Dude, because if I take
it too serious, then everyone's going to think it's real. And
when you're in a self-defense mode, you kind of just got to say,
you know, anything to save face because when people are calling
a every I mean, you got to let it roll on the shoulders and make
a joke. And so, the >> Dude, this guy is so Dude, this
guy is so bad at defending himself. He's so bad at answering
these questions.
Why the [__]
When you're in self-defensive mode, you kind of got to say, you
know, anything you can to save face. So, the truth doesn't matter.
What are you What the are you saying? Like, you Oh, you just
lie. Just say anything to save face. >> The best way to
defend yourself is to make the other person basically a
>> I I didn't believe that,
It's the mentally ill [__] defense every time. do
that. Well, that's what you've done. I mean, the first thing
you said when you testified today was that she was the most forward
woman that you ever had in your life on day one.
>> I don't think calling someone forward is calling them
a really when you talked about you said you like long tongues
and she exposed her tongue. You thought that was appropriate
behavior. It was probably inappropriate. That's probably what
made it attractive. Maybe though. Can we have a break? Um, I'm
having hives. I'm just not used to it. Okay. So, do you not see
that you are painting her in particular light when you talk about
these things in open court?
I can only give you an accurate representation of the truth.
If it makes someone appear in a certain way, that's not really
against or not
really my intention. I'm just trying to give you accurate representation
of how
>> Okay. So, tell me this.
>> But, your honor, she has an only fans. How could I even
insult somebody with an only fans? He's a for a living. >> Miss,
my client actually had a house that she was renting in South
Austin at the time that she moved in with you. Is that correct?
Yes, ma'am. And she was actually making about $10,000 a month
or so. Isn't that correct? I don't think it was making that much
to No way. What I'm asking? Oh, is that your understanding that
she because you have testified that she didn't have money that's
why she needed to move in with you? Correct. And I need to slow
down. I testify to that. Yeah, you absolutely did. That you were
the hero who got her to move in with you. Yes. For some reason,
in direct examination, you talked about how you were a total
hero for letting this woman, you take care of her. She She could
just move in for free. It was not a problem. >> I'm sorry.
>> Yeah, that was you. >> That was you. I thought
I just said she didn't enjoy her house and she wanted to move
in. Okay. So, she actually
broke her lease. Uh-huh. You literally said that, Tone. Oh my
god. To move in with you is >> No way. She gave him permission
to MAKE THIS THEATRICAL. UH, I don't think there's any problem
with Miz making it theatrical. Realistically, Miz gave me the
document. I could go read this myself. I am fine with him making
fun of Tee. I'm fine with him making fun of Teone. This Teone
testimony is totally You're totally justified in laughing at
it. It is a joke in and of itself. Okay. I have no problem with
Msk making light of it because he is a joke. Okay. Teone that
is. Teone is a joke. >> Is that correct? Yes. And there
were actually a not a bunch of roaches. There was one roach.
And you all made it a joke to tell people that there were roaches
all over the house when there was only one.
Oh, okay. Is that correct? Oh, that could be correct. It's been
so long, dude. I just accepted that what it is. I thought like
that story you made up right off the bat. That was like obviously
right. You're just like totally
just totally right now. That's her way of just she couldn't let
it go. She actually couldn't let that one go. The lawyer couldn't
even let it go. The lawyer had to be like, you know, you're like
a lying piece of [__] right? You know, nobody believes
that story, right? About the roaches. You know, you know, you're
like embellishing that hugely. And I'm just going to point that
out. Not really relevant to the case. I just want everybody to
know you're
>> I cannot believe this is real. I cannot believe that.
>> Yeah, she couldn't let it go, miss. She couldn't let
it go.
The fact that that this guy told this fake Reddit everybody clap
story. She could. The lawyer couldn't even let it go. >> Really
did this. There was one roach in Teto trying to make it seem
so much more important than it was on the witness stand. This
dude is such a manipulative liar. He tried to make it in court
that he was just like, "The driver thought I was cool. The doctor
had long hair. My locks were in the wind." He's just lied.
>> And then everybody
just 20 minutes later, there was just one roach.
>> By the way, I have no idea. Do you think she asked Pink
about this? I would love to know if for some reason that came
up in their preparing for this test for the testimony if it came
up for some reason, but I I prefer to believe that actually the
lawyer leaned over and was like, "What the [__] is
he talking about right now?" And Pink's like, "I don't know.
There's like one roach." And she figured out a way to roll that
into the
just to make him look like a complete.
>> That could be correct. Things alone that I just >> You
love to see it. >> Except that what it is. I just thought
she had more roaches, dude. It just their faces were melting.
It's weird. Well, wouldn't that be different than what you actually
told the law enforcement officer? Remember the detail you just
went into a minute ago?
Yeah. About the police stop on the way. She called because there
were roaches, dude. Okay. And then you had her sell all of her
furniture from her rental house. Yep. Okay. Well, I wouldn't
say I had her do that, but that's definitely happened. Okay.
Okay. So, you and also at the time of the lawsuit, you wanted
her to sign an NDA because you didn't want all of your ex's wife
allegations public. Isn't that correct?
Can you can you repeat that? Sorry. Um I I just imagine like
Teton's lawyers like giving him like cues behind him like a like
a a catcher like telling him to shut the up.
Sure. We talked about the lawsuit. Correct. Uh of course. And
you tried to paint it that you were not involved in it. In fact,
wanted nothing to do with it. Correct. I tried my hardest not
to be part of it, but obviously when Pig was worried about it,
I tried to assist my girl. And in fact, what was the attorney's
name that handled that? I'm actually not familiar. Um, attorney
>> There's no way he's more involved than he let on. There's
no
way that he could be. There's no way. He said, "I didn't know
anything about that. I encouraged her not to. I discouraged her
from do he doing it heavily and then he recommended like a lawyer
to >> that guy on YouTube. I got him a mythic deal. Aaron.
You don't remember Aaron? No, I'm not familiar with Aaron. Okay.
Are you familiar with Alex Content? Not familiar with that guy
either. Okay. And you're not originally You weren't originally
behind the lawsuit when it started, but after you all broke up
is when you withdrew your support of the
One more time. Sorry. Um Um
[__] I need a Sure. You were actually >> Oh,
no. I don't think so. I don't think that works time. >> Your
concern was not whether she would do it or not. you were concerned
more about the NDA language and some violation of that that may
possibly involve you. Correct. So, Teone is basically admitting
here that he was helping Pink when he wasn't allowed to because
he signed a NDA uh with with uh FEM. He was not supposed to be
helping her at all, but he just did. His excuse was I tried to
support Pink with whatever she needed. So he literally admits
here he broke the NDA with
>> I
don't know if he's admitting that because that would require
further questions but that probably is I'm guessing that he does
admit that basically in the next sentence here >> with
pink with with >> right like that's not an admission itself
that's why the lawyer is going to ask weren't you concerned >> he
literally admits it here that he tried to help her with every
what she needed and he broke the NDA this is >> the kitnetic
thing is obviously
>> insane and In fact, what your concern was not whether
she would do it or not. You were concerned more about the NDA
language and some violation of that may possibly involve you.
Correct. I I um my intentions were too >> Oh, never mind.
>> This is the I think the NDA that hopefully Pink and
F were going to >> kind of just assist Pink. I mean, obviously
I think I could toss myself a bone in those situations. I'll
I'll do it. But I mean, it's mainly just about Pink, you know,
being okay. Okay. You are you would agree with me as you've indicated
that it's important to be honest with your viewers. Correct.
Correct. All right. And you've told your viewers that you have
schizophrenia. Correct. Yeah. And you in fact suffer from schizophrenia.
Is that right?
>> Wait. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. I looked at something.
>> I looked at something. I looked at a message. That's
my bad. That's my bad. >> You know, being
I could toss myself a bone in those situations. I thought,
dude, I need to pay more attention. I Every time something totally
gets said that's like not something a normal person would say,
I assume it's him ad libing the weird chud
character that he's doing for Tech Tone. But he literally said,
I mean, obviously I think if I can toss myself a bone in those
situations, I'll do it. No, he actually said that as in
just to assist pink.
Oh, that is scummy. This guy is actually scum.
Uh, no. Like obviously if I could, you know, if I could get a
little NDA action in there that says you can't go over after
techone with any of this salt stuff, then I'm going to do that.
But uh that's what he's saying, right? That's in actuality what
he's saying. Yeah. If I could make it so she could uh never bring
up the the allegations she has against me, if I could do that
and throw myself a little bone in those situations, then yeah,
I'm going to do that. Okay. >> Okay. Okay. You are.
Dude, I I'm getting like I'm actually thinking that he was done
with this relationship way sooner, right? Like he was actually
probably
around the time they moved into the new place or something. And
I think he kept this relationship going because he knew that
he needed free he needed Pink to have this lawsuit because he
wanted this to happen. He wanted it to work out this way. Like
I
it's so weird to get him like to to do this and then be like,
"No, no, no. Make sure the NDA make sure when she signs the NDA,
it says she can't go after me on this either. Like, are you serious?
>> You would agree with me as you've indicated that it's
important to be honest with your viewers. Correct.
>> Bro, what? >> And you've told your viewers that
you will have schizophrenia. Correct.
Yeah. And you in fact suffer from schizophrenia. Is that right?
No. I mean, yes. See, I told you I schizophrenia. I I don't even
think I have. And by suffer, you mean diagnosed? Yes, I wouldn't
really consider it
>> I mean,
he would consider it suffering. He's described it as suffering
before.
He has literally said that he wanted to like end it for a period
because he couldn't sleep. I think he was having like terrible
sleeping issues, right? Because of the schizophrenia. >> It's
um >> like he's talked about. >> Who is your mental
health provider that tells you this information? Chat TV. Um,
my mental health provider was just like a psychiatrist from New
Mexico State University back in freshman year.
So, for 15 years, Teone just didn't really care about the fact
that he had schizophrenia and was off his
>> I guess you could maybe think that I'm guessing once
you have a diagnosis
that you can go to your like general practitioner and get meds
for it. He just said
>> it is a little weird that she said who tells you this
now? Who's your like mental health provider now? And he goes
I had one back at school like uh like 10 15 years ago. I had
one back then. Like no no no. Who's providing your medication
now? Uh what do you mean? >> I see a psychiatrist from
New Mexico State University.
>> Universities have psychiatrists on campus like that?
Um I mean mine did. I don't know. Mine had a lot of counselors.
I don't know if they were full-on psych psychiatrists,
but my university definitely had counselors. >> Freshman
year of his college.
Holy sh
>> probably refer you to a psychiat. >> Sometimes
I think I see things that aren't there. And he goes, "You're
schizophrenic. Take these pills." And dude, you're sick. Wait,
wait a minute. You said you're on your stream. The court heard
it. Yeah. That you are schizophrenic and you have hallucinations
once a month. Is that correct? Yeah. And are you telling this
court Oh, he's caught >> under oath that you are not seeking
mental health for a serious mental health condition. >> It's
very much under control. I mean, the the worst that
>> now he's caught. It's a rock in a hard place. He's victimized
himself so much on stream. He's made this so bad on stream before,
right? He's made it like a thing that's kept him up kept him
up that he has these major hallucinations that cause possible
violent episodes. He's told all these stories on his stream and
now she's sitting here like, "Wait, you literally don't have
a psychiatrist right now. You're a schizophrenic, a diagnosed
schizophrenic who doesn't take their medicine, has testified
you don't take your medicine. You don't have a medical health
practitioner, a mental health practitioner you talk to. Are you
out of your mind?" >> What I really get is like, you know,
like Pink said, "I'll see a face and I'll almost someone in a
car accident." It's like, it's whatever, dude. And you think
that's okay to go out without medical supervision? Like, dude,
are you really bringing that up right now, Doc? Were you really
branding up?
>> I mean,
okay, that's one thing. All right, that is like one thing possibly,
bro. That is not an excuse to not have a mental health professional
that you talk to, right? You should be keeping somebody like
uh what is it? Keeping them a breast of the situation. Okay,
you you got to be keeping somebody up to date. You got to be
talking to someone, right? You can't just be like, I don't need
the meds at all. Again, can we get the real lawyer in here, not
this?
Are you aware of the consequences of being an untreated schizophrenic?
No. Are you aware that being untreated can lead to worsening
psychosis, including hallucinations and delusions?
I'm sure of a more severe case of
Oh, man. It's so back and forth. I I really don't think he has
it. I think he's clearly made some up. I feel like he made this
up. He got out of like some problematic thing in his life one
time from talking about how he had schizophrenia and he's just
rolled with that for years and years and years and now he's getting
asked about it. Like seriously, do you actually do you actually
like you're claiming you have schizophrenia? He just kept using
it as an excuse when he do something bad when something bad would
happen. And
now rubber meets the road is
and he looks insane. He looks like not just schizophrenia insane,
he looks genuinely insane.
And there's no way to resolve the ambiguity here. Either you
are a undiagnosed
like unmedicated schizoph sorry, you're a diagnosed unmedicated
schizophrenic who is a threat to everybody around you or you're
a total psychopath who's lied about having schizophrenia to get
out of like problematic events in your life for years and you're
a total psychopath who's a threat to everybody around you. Like
there really is no in between here.
JABRINA WOULD BE HASSAN BER.
WELL, but tell me this. Are you a licensed medical professional?
No, >> Yeah,
you realize you are a unmedicated
diagnosed schizophrenic who is saying who's self diagnosing now.
Well, I have only have I only have light schizophrenia. It's
just a little light schizophrenia. Okay, it's not major schizophrenia.
Doesn't really do much. You understand that this [__]
with your ability to perceive reality? You can't tell. You are
like a drunk person telling me that you're not drunk right now.
You're a drunk person. You are impaired by definition. You cannot
tell me whether or not your schizophrenia is bad enough to cope
with.
>> Okay. So, how would you know the serious or not your
case of schizophrenia is? Damn, that's a really good point. I
guess it's there's no way he talks about a beautiful mind. There's
no [__] way he talks about a beautiful [__]
mind. Look up the year the beautiful like sorry, not the beautiful
mind. A beautiful mind, right? There's no way.
Wait, listen. There's this movie about a really smart schizophrenic
man. And it's sad. It's tragic. Just like my life. And that's
basically me. I'm basically that guy. I'm Is that Kevin Spy,
by the way? He is kind of like Kevin Spy. Or is it? It's not.
It's definitely Kevin Spy, isn't it?
>> It's so poetic that he picked an actual for the guy
he's like. >> Kind of goofy.
There's a movie called the beautiful mind. And so I was like,
man, his mind is messed up and mine is nothing compared to that.
So, you know, I HEAR PEOPLE LIKE, >> "OH, IT'S RUSSELL
CROWE. IT'S Russell Crow." No, it's Russell Crow. I Dude, I remember
this movie. I remember this movie being in theaters. Not theaters.
Um, the movie store when I was like a little kid.
Yeah, I remember it being in the I remember like it. But it is
Russell Cro.
Damn it. Too good to be true. Too good to be true. I I knew I
was too young. >> Talk to people who aren't there. >> I'd
hoped it was serious, >> but I'm just like, what's that?
Oh, it's gone. Oh my god. Are you kidding me? He mentions the
beautiful mind.
And that's his reason why he doesn't get a schizophrenia treated
ever for 15
It's insane.
It's it's it's literally insane. Um, actually, I saw a movie.
And by the way, what's the ending of A Beautiful Mind? I thought
that ended tragically. Doesn't that end really tragically?
How does this end? Plot. Nash returns to Princeton approaching
his old rival Hansen, now head of the mathematics department,
who allows him to work out of the library and audit classes.
Over the next two decades, Nash learns to ignore his hallucin
hallucinations, and by the late 1970s, is allowed to teach again.
In 1994, oh no, he actually recovers and he's fine. I thought
this ended tragically. Never mind. Dude, I I clearly didn't watch
this movie or don't remember this movie
at all.
Oh, hold on. Wait, wait, hold on. Frustrated with the side effects
of his antisycchotic medication, particular erectile dysfunction,
he secretly stops taking it. He encounters Parker, who urges
him to continue his assignment in a shed near his home. Oh, I
feel like there's some overlap here, isn't there? Okay. All right.
All right.
Interesting. I
Whatever, man. Whatever,
>> It's because it's just like I don't this is it's not
as bad.
>> I feel like
I want to look through that movie start to finish and see how
many parallels there are with Tectton's like stories about his
life cuz I feel like it's I feel like I'm witnessing a Tom Foolery
situation. I I feel like we're seeing Tom Foolery. I feel like
it's again Tom Fery totally making up like basically grabbing
from popular culture the events of his life 100%. You guys don't
know who Tom Fery is. He's just a guy who used to interact with
the stream. Just a pathological liar who made up a bunch of stories
about his life. Okay, I truly believe that that seems to be the
case with Teeone, that he will just make up stories entirely
to make himself sound cool because he knows nobody's going to
check into them and then when they do check into them, it's like,
"Oh, this guy's like, this guy literally took his schizophrenia
directly from a beautiful mind. That's who he thinks he is."
And that's his reason why he doesn't get his schizophrenia treated
ever for 15 years
is because he's just like, I don't this is it's not as bad as
this guy a movie.
Are you kidding? >> No, he's like that guy. That guy learned
to overcome That's a movie about somebody overcoming their schizophrenia
through like learning how to work around it, right? That this
guy secretly stopped taking his like his pills.
Kidding me.
Tomorrow night we're doing movie night. We are watching A Beautiful
Mind. Oh my god. Are you serious? Are you kidding me? He straight
up says, I guess it's kind of goofy. There's this movie called
The Beautiful Mind. And so I was like, man, his is messed up
and mine is nothing compared to that. So, you know, I hear people
like who like talk to people like, do you think you talk to
this is unironically this is real life.
Um, well, there's a movie about a guy who's schizophrenic and
like my schizophrenia isn't that bad and since like that guy
that guy stopped taking his meds and it worked out for him. So
if my if my schizophrenia isn't as bad as this movie schizophrenics
and he stopped taking his med bed med bed med bed med bed med
bed med bed med bed med bed meds why wouldn't that work out for
me
right that's pretty solid logic right guys >> Mr. Owl from
the uh Tootsie Pop commercial, dude. Like, you're almost uh Jimmy
here apparently. You ruined people's lives for decades and you're
just like, "Oh, a movie says I'm not as bad. You're insane, Larry
or Techone. You're a insane dude. This is insanity." And honestly,
you need a stray jacket. You actually need a stray jacket. You
>> I I think he needs a straight jacket because I believe
he's I fully believe he's lying about this. I fully believe he's
lying about this.
I need to think of I need to hear the other situations where
he relies on schizophrenia to get out of something like when
he almost hits that guy with his car and then he says, "Well,
I saw somebody standing behind him." I need to know the other
situations he gets out of with schizophrenia because I do not
believe it. You are crazy, bro. You don't just need this protective
order. You need a stray jacket. You're nuts. You are actually
nuts. You ruined your court case in 30 minutes because you just
wouldn't shut up and you lied under oath twice now. And now you're
saying the reason why you don't think your schizophrenia is bad
is not because of anything with with psychology, anything with
anything. It's the beautiful mind, >> brother. Like
it's not even that he should be cancelled. I'm not going to say
this guy should be cancelled. This guy should be
I if I had this transcript out I would not be able to cope with
being a streamer. I would not be able to cope with the people
coming to my chat and mocking the out of me justifiably so. Like
it would be over.
This is so embarrassing. Like it's not even that this guy should
be cancelled. If he has any amount of shame, which we already
know he doesn't, but if he had any amount of shame, this would
be enough to chase you off the [__] internet. This
is sad. >> What the [__]
What the I can't believe this. I cannot Can you guys believe
this? Can you believe this?
Okay. Are you aware that it can lead to chronic? You have a neurobiological
deterioration from not getting treatment from schizophrenia?
I can absolutely believe that. I feel nuts.
Okay. Are you aware that medication and therapy can sign?
>> Dude, this is like total versus somebody who's like
just asking legitimate questions. You're worried that it could
lead to chronic you can have neurobbiological deterioration from
not getting treatment for schizophrenia. I could absolutely believe
that.
You realize like you might actually develop like your schizophrenia
will worsen if you just are untreated, right? Like if you just
aren't treated, your schizophrenia can worsen significantly.
I could absolutely believe that. He's like he's
believe it. Believe it.
I absolutely believe it, dude. It's It's just another way to
That answer right there. I can absolutely believe that is just
another
piece of proof that he does not have this mental illness. He
almost I don't even necessarily believe that he was even jokingly
diagnosed. Like there's just no way that you would
Hey, you have this illness that you've never sought medication
for or you you've stopped taking medication for. Yes. Do you
realize that that can actually like destroy your neuronal pathways,
have significant long-term damage? Your psychosis will get worse.
Uh, I can absolutely believe that. That sounds sounds right to
me.
I'm out of my
>> Your psychosis and allow for better functioning. I believe
that for sure, dude. Dude, dude, the next question
he he literally said to both both questions, are you aware that
this can cause long-term neurobiological
I could absolutely believe that. Okay. Are you aware that medication
therapy could significantly reduce your psychosis and allow for
better functioning? Yeah, I absolutely believe that, too.
Are you,
bro? I'm starting to believe that he actually got the 10ear the
10ear thing for this testimony for the schizophrenia testimony.
They're like, "Bro, I can't lock you up, but you holy, you cannot
have guns. Holy, you cannot have guns. You can literally never
have guns." This is like she actually saw that she needed to
intervene cuz somebody's going to get killed. Like maybe not
pink. Someone's going to get [__] shot by this guy.
This guy is out of his mind.
This is This is like
I don't know how to explain it. Somehow this to me is like the
most frightening part of the testimony. He's sitting here and
trying to gigachad in like like he's Twitch streaming through
hey your your schizophrenia will significantly deterior function
over time. Yeah, I believe that. Are you aware that medication
therapy could reduce this? I believe that too. No, you don't.
Because if you believed that, if you knew that, if you cared
about that, if there was any part of you that wasn't like totally
in denial of that, then you would be doing those things.
>> Yeah, like for sure. >> Okay. So, what? >> Hello,
Buddhis.
Thank you for the three gifted subs. >> Medications are
you currently taking? >> Thank you. Thank you.
>> I just take multivitamins and fish oil, so nothing,
dude.
I like gummy vitamins.
>> What do you think his lawyer is doing right now? What
What >> pulling his hair out, dude? his lawyers are actually
or I don't know just like laughing that they cast the checks
on
like at some point.
Is it not almost malpractice on the lawyer's part here? Like
this is so disastrous. This has gone so disastrously.
Is it not near malpractice on the lawyer's part to have allowed
this to occur? Like it's actually crazy that it's gone down like
this. Dude, it's wild. It's it's lawyers are doing right here.
I I imagine they're just ordering Uber Eats because they just
realize this is so they're like picking what what what uh maybe
like a restaurant to go to and just being like, "Yeah, you want
to go to here?" Like, "Yeah." Like >> I I just imagine
they're just like, "We're so dumb with this guy." Like he is
insane. She's literally The lawyer's asking fantastic question,
Pink Juice lawyer. Fantastic question. And Pekone is just folding
under the pressure.
I just take multivitamins and fish oil. So nothing like you really
don't take anything for your schizophrenia. Not one thing that
you even a pseudocience that you believe in. You take multivitamins
and fish oil.
Okay. And what therapy are you doing to help reduce your psychosis
and allow for better functioning? No therapy, ma'am.
I I thought for sure he was going to say, "I've started going
to church." >> When was the last time you sought
>> With a registered professional. Um I don't recall. I
don't believe I've ever just kind of just, you know, just checking
in with my homies and seeing if I'm okay and talking about my
problem. >> Yeah, he did not get a he did not get a real
schizophrenia diagnosis. He got told this is like he got a schizophrenia
diagnosis in the same way that food shops got told to
to deal with her POCD so-called. Okay. The exact same thing.
One time I kind of talked to a doctor and they said maybe it
could be something kind of like what you're saying and then they
just ran with it, right? It's the exact same. Man,
what a crocus. This guy is a pathological liar. An obvious, clear
pathological liar. It's never been more obvious than right now.
Anybody who watches this guy, you are a [__] You
deserve to have your money taken from you. You deserve to get
taken for a ride. You are a ro shot Asmin Gold could listen to
this, read this, and go, I'm going to stand with this guy. No
shot. Asmin Gold is out. Everybody is out. There is not going
to be a single sweeper left in the camp for techone. The only
person who's there is legal mindset because he's having a mental
breakdown. He thinks this might be his shot.
There's no way you could read this and stick with this guy. This
is nuts, man. >> That's about it. >> I didn't think
it could possibly get worse. It's gotten so much worse. I don't
know, dude. Is there any chance that his lawyer comes back up
or do they just like do they just phone it in after
I don't know where you go after this.
>> No way, bro.
No way. I feel like at one point Techone said he goes to therapy
or he's going to start therapy. Didn't he say that? I feel like
he absolutely said that. >> He said he got diagnosed by
somebody at his university. I think that he might have gone for
one session one time and said, "Sometimes I think I see things."
And they were like, "Well, it could be schizophrenia or something."
And he's like, "Oh, what do I do about that?" that they're like,
"Well, if it were that you would take like medications like this
or that." He's like, "Okay." And then he left. He probably got
somebody else to write him a prescription for that. He got those
pills. He tried them for a little bit, didn't like them. And
I I don't even know about that. I don't even know, bro. I don't
even know.
I It's just clear to me that he either he he doesn't have it.
Like, he's just lying about his diagnosis.
He's almost certainly lying about how often he has hallucinations,
if he ever has them.
Relevant tweet. Relevant tweet. Relevant tweet. Hold on.
Hold on. What is this? What is this relevant tweet? Give me a
second. Pull it up right now.
Uh, hey brother. Therapy changed my life and there's no shame
in it. It might Oh. >> Oh [__] Oh [__]
>> Dude, there's just no way. There's simply no way. Pathological
liar. actual pathological liar.
Complete and utter destruction.
Run this guy off the internet. He cannot be taken seriously.
He is a total loser who has lied about everything he's ever stated.
He has no principles. He has no beliefs. He's just a completely
spineless principalist grifter. Get him the out of here. Holy
[__] He lied under oath. No, he didn't. He told the
truth under oath. He lied on the internet.
Not shocking to most, I guess, but he he just went on the internet
and lied. This is absolutely what it what it really is is he's
just never gone to therapy. Narcissists like him, they they can't
go to therapy. They can't take it seriously. There's no shot.
I It's Dude,
and the the performance of like there's no shame in going to
therapy. At least I say I put things in the pit, bro. Come on,
man. Dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude. So, his working
on himself is sitting around a fire talking to his homies and
taking fish oil pills. That's working on yourself when you have
Are you kidding me?
You have schizophrenia is what you're trying to claim you have
from New Mexico. And you >> Exactly. Exactly what you're
trying to claim you have. He's never gone. He literally saw a
beautiful mind. He was getting in trouble for something. He made
some hallucination story. >> He never treated it. Which
she's 100% right in knowing this and she's smart for understanding
schizophrenia. The more you don't treat it, the worse it can
get. the worst it can get.
Okay. When was the last time you sought therapy with a register?
>> Bro, could I get a Could I get a time stamp? If anybody
has a moment, could I get a time stamp for the legal mindset
stream when we get to them talking about the schizophrenia? I
have to see how he reacts to the schizophrenia part. Does he
even get there or does he skip it? I have to see how he represents
that and how he sweeps for this cuz this is so this is so awful
to listen to. Like it's this this has to hit him like a ton of
bricks when he starts to realize that this guy is like a complete
and utter
It has to hit him like a ton of bricks. There's no way he could
keep sweeping >> professional just I don't recall. I don't
believe I've ever kind of just uh you know just um throw a frisbee
around, you know, see a tree melt and uh >> dude, she's
actually she's going even further, right? She's making the comparison
I made, which is like, are you aware that the like the main downside
of schizophrenia, the reason so many people get off of their
meds is because they think they don't need their meds. And then
once they're off of the meds, they cannot evaluate reality enough.
They cannot identify and stay tethered to reality enough to ever
get back on the meds. They they will think the meds are the worst
thing. They will never be able to reattach and truly objectively
identify their problems and you are like once that happens. That
is one of the biggest challenges is you do not have introspection
in a way that somebody who's not schizophrenic does. Just like
you cannot solve your own problems or something. >> You
are blind to your own problems. Your job right to identify your
problems. You need to be able to see the color red, but you're
color blind.
>> I don't know. Like, dude, like what? Okay. Are you aware
that one of your ch ch ch ch ch ch ch ch ch challenges of schizophrenia
is lack of insight by the person suffering from
I actually um I just never looked that up, dude. I'm sorry.
I actually did not know that. Yes, you did. Yes, you did. Yes,
you did. Because it's an obvious fact of reality for anybody
who even remotely understands what any schizotiple thing is,
right? Like the fact that you're hallucinating means you can't
identify reality well enough to know whether or not you could
trust yourself to know whether or not it's mild or major schizophrenia.
Obviously, that is a just a natural consequence. You literally
if you have an 80 IQ, you can connect those dots. Not even remotely.
It's not even remotely close. >> Okay, Pink. Did I ever
do >> No, no, no. He knows this. whether or not he has
schizophrenia. He knows this. Wait, did you know that with schizophrenia,
you might not be able to tell if you have schizophrenia or how
bad it is? No, I didn't know that. Um, wait, hold on. If he was,
he doesn't have it. It's true that he doesn't have it. We pointed
this out many times, but I'm saying that everybody knows this.
Even schizophrenics know this. Even schizophrenics know that
probably like an illness like schizophrenia would prevent you
from be able to see reality.
>> Do that to you? I'm sorry. I'm actually if that's the
case, I'm sorry, but like I didn't know. Am I allowed to do that?
Can I talk to Pig? Can I just like get up and TALK TO HER? PIG,
CAN I LIKE NO.
I actually did not know that. Okay. And that people with schizophrenia
often don't realize they're ill, making them resistant to treatment.
Are you aware of that? No. I I didn't I didn't I didn't know
that schizophrenia often people don't realize they are ill, making
them resistant to treatment. I didn't know.
Okay, judge. May I approach? All right, we're going to look at
this one first. You've indicated that you were immediately called
upon. Correct.
So, you finally see my side, huh? Finally. I'm not the bad guy.
Yes, dude. Yes, I did. Yes, I could look at this one first. You've
indicated that you were immediately called a
correct.
Wait, where did where where did my client accuse you of being
a
That's a main plot point of a beautiful mind that he can identify
whether or not he's schizophrenic, right? He doesn't think he's
sick. He thinks he's smart enough to know that he's not sick.
>> Okay, judge. May I approach? All right, we're going
to look at this one first.
>> You've indicated that you were immediately called a
correct?
So, you finally see my side, huh? Finally. I'm not the bad guy.
Yes. Yes, I did. Yes, I did, dude. Now, let's all get out of
here. Come on, guys. I'll buy you smoothies. You want smoothies?
And that was a direct result of the comments made by my client
on her sub account. Is that correct? Yes, ma'am. And you would
tell me where on that threads you're looking at, will you tell
the court where exhibit number that is referring to the one with
her tweet? Um, I drew like a a circle. We do that on YouTube
to like get more views. Like, we draw an arrow to a circle. Like,
it's sick. It actually works. Loro actually made this for me.
Um, am I referencing the picture? Yes. Okay. So, what's the exhibit
number? Is that exhibit 11? Thank you. Yep. Like, I'm doing way
too much work for this. Now, tell me where on the side she refers
to you as a
exactly. Where did my client call you a you
meatthead? >> Nowhere. Like, not at all. Okay. Did you
hear my question where I just asked you where she said you were
blaming her for them calling you a the very next day?
when someone's okay with calling you a you're not going to draw
the line a or abuser because once you kind of open the gateway
of like hey this guy's a if anybody's ever going to fight him
on well he's a but I wouldn't say a there's no way because she
opened the gate
all of their gates opened up sorry because she opened the gate
all of their gates opened as well now people are willing to call
me a they're willing to call me a beastia uh Wait, what? Uh,
what is it when you [__] animals? It's not It's What's
the word? A zoo file. A zoo file. They're willing to call me
a zoo file. They're willing to call me anything. They'll call
me anything now. Yes.
>> People are just It opens the floodgates. They're going
to call me anything they
>> He's He's trying this. And you're going to try to make
my client responsible for
>> You're going to make my client responsible I want now,
>> dude. Okay. Okay. And you believe that even though my
client never referred to you as a it's her fault that you were
called that. Once you get a guy called a I don't think there's
anything worse than that. So, might as well just throw it on
the the the grill and call me a
Are you kidding me? Techone. Are you kidding me? I I would say
>> Oh, hold on.
Oh, she's going to cook it with the next >> There's probably
there's You are serious. you were trying to say that the reason
why you're called a >> this is like this is what being
like a chronic self victimizer gets you by the way is you think
he thinks because he gets the filter down as a streamer and somebody
who victimizes himself all the time a total narcissist he gets
to filter down to just the people who will constantly be sick
offensive who will constantly tell him what he wants to hear
tell him that he's correct right and now he's up here and he
sounds
um actually
yeah uh listen she call me because she she did she she didn't
she assume she asserted that assault happened but then other
people called him a right
people called him a and that that's her fault and then other
people called him a and that's her fault he is going to make
every problem in his life her fault and then complain that she
can't take accountability he's going to write the list of things
out for her to take to her therapist hey pink you can't take
accountability for the things you've done wrong kill your
self in a video game. Teto
>> because she said you assaulted her. Teone, it's not
because of that. It's because of the gotcha games you play, bro.
Like, are you kidding me? It's not because of that. It was never
because of that. He's [__] lying.
>> And with that, if you guys were watching on Twitch,
head over to kick.com. No, >> keep in mind is a right-wing
grifter that tries to pretend that he actually cares about God
and and and the justice system. Yet, he's straight up lying under
oath. He's straight up lying under oath. You think, >> "Oh,
we we obviously don't believe in people hurting themselves. That's
why we say in a video game, in Minecraft, >> children is
not nearly as bad as being called a rape rapist."
>> Exactly the question I would ask. Oh, so you think children?
I mean,
it's that's not the point he's making. He's saying like like
people will will web on other things, right? That's not the point
he's trying to make. The point he's trying to make is totally
This is not what he's saying that he thinks >> it's not
bad as being called a right techone. Is that what you're saying?
You think children is not nearly as bad as being called a
>> No, it's actually terrible. [__]
>> Okay. Let's talk. >> But it's not worse >> about
Give me one second. >> Or it's not better. So, let's go
over a couple of You can't Okay. The those sub tweets that you
were getting and receiving in those days after, those actually
don't show anything the same day after her tweet. Isn't that
correct? Yeah. I thought the 20th. Okay. So, your testimony was
that you received it within moments of it being published on
the internet was incorrect, right? No, it was correct. The tweets
that I pulled were just kind of like, >> oh no.
Oh, no.
He didn't pull any of the actual evidence for his points >> like
last second. I could probably dig that. But I haven't dug. I
dug for like 15 minutes. >> No shot, dude.
minutes. He dug for. He didn't.
Bro, you are a millionaire. Pay somebody else to do it. Say what
happened. Pay somebody else to do it.
Literally just pay somebody.
What is your problem? What is your major malfunction? I maybe
dug for like 15 minutes. Okay.
You're not taking this seriously. You're not taking it seriously
at all. >> And that's exactly what I said, Twitter. That
is exactly what I said. And that's what people didn't want to
believe me on. They thought I was a liar.
By the way, let's see what this is. Is >> that true? >> Hey,
brother. Therapy changed my life. And there's no shame in it.
There's
>> Oh, here's this Emerald Apple loser right here. >> Get
this on the stream. We should talk to this person. Get this loser
on the stream. I don't know if this is healthy, but my therapy
is beating people and getting beaten up in kendo. At the end
of class, I feel like a million bucks after even after gaining
a couple bruises afterwards.
This person's a total loser. No way. Techone, there's no way
you said this. Therapy changed my life and there's no shame in
it. It might take some time to find the right one, but it's all
worth
Yep.
I knew it. I knew I've seen tech tweet that this lion respond.
I'm
>> Are you kidding me? Techone, you lied under oath or
you lied in general. You've lied. You just lie.
>> He literally lies. >> Disgusting. Deranged. >> Where
piece of
>> By the way, just a totally pathological proven pathological
liar. The second he goes on the stand, he's getting asked questions.
He's not lying now. Yeah. Okay, bro. I went through every time
Tee talked about Skitsone Filmont and he had a better health
sponsorship. Wait, like Better Health. Wait, what's Better Health?
You're not talking about That can't possibly be like the Dr.
K thing, right? That's not Wait, hold on. Is that a therapy finding
service? A therapist service? Like a cheap therapy service? Better
Help? I don't even know what Better Help is. I don't know what
Better Help is. Yeah, somebody wants to tell me. Therapy on your
phone. Okay.
>> He probably lied on stream. Yeah, he did lie. I'm sure
he I'm sure he didn't lie here. I'm sure he lied on stream. He
wouldn't lie here. Well, he did lie here, but >> no, for
right now, he's not lying here because if he wants to press that
he has been diagnosed,
that is something that can be fact checked, right?
That's why he's not lying here because he knows that if he lies
about his medical history here, that can be subpoenaed. He just
watched it get subpoena subpoenaed for pink.
That could be challenged. That could be tested and he would be
[__] for lying under oath. So he is not lying here
because it's something that he could be fact checked on when
he can't really be fact checked on it or it's like a judgment
call or he's like could say he's unsure.
That's different. But he has represented multiple times that
he is a diagnosed schizophrenic. And so when he says that and
he says like oh I haven't gotten therapy he knows he can't say
well I got therapy here or if you're getting therapy currently
you should be able to name the person. He's not going to name
somebody he's not never talked to right.
What therapy were you doing? Uh, Teresa. No, ma'am. Okay. When
was the last time you sought therapy?
>> I don't believe I've ever sought therapy. Okay.
But it's all worth it.
>> blocked me.
>> Okay. When was the last pedophile rapist? Correct. Yep.
And that was a direct result of the comments made by my client
on her sub account. Correct. Yes, ma'am. Would you tell me where
on the threads? We've already went over this. We'll keep going.
Uh some people call you a uh they're going to start calling you
a
judge gets her a second. So let's just go over a couple of You
can't those sub tweets that you were getting and receiving in
these days after those actually don't show up for any to dig
up these just for court today. >> 15 minutes. Sorry. 15
minutes.
>> So wait a minute. This has been on file since August.
You've known about this since at least the video your video on
November 21st of 2024. And you're telling this court under oath
that you only spent 15 minutes to dig up these just for court
today.
>> And you did do you remember getting online and telling
all of your
I've got it all backed up. I've got all the texts. I've got all
the messages. I've got all the videos. I've got all of it backed
up. I am a cautious man. I am a cautious man. Okay. I am a cautious
cautious man.
I've got everything backed up, Pink. You don't know what's It's
war now, Pink. I am a cautious man and you with the wrong one.
You've got aggro now, Pink.
God, what a performative
loser. >> Followers that you just had all the evidence
back in November of 2024 and you were ready to produce it all.
Of course. Okay. So, where are those messages from 2020 that
show or from the the 20th of 2020 that show sorry November 20,
2024 that show that you were immediately received notifications
of her post. >> Notifications aren't obvious, dude. They
got to be from moderators first in my Discord as well as calls
from the higherups in my company like the big boys like Asmin.
Dude, I love that guy.
>> So, where are those messages? Why didn't you bring those
messages? Um, and then >> I do believe, by the way, this
is what happens anytime like um
anything something's like popping off with me, that's who messages
me first is usually like um
people who are mods, people who are like super invested, people
who like you and are like, "Hey, heads up. This >> the
bigger tweeter started to pop up my day. I'm not really sure.
Maybe you can refresh my memory exactly what time this was posted."
And you've indicated that you get have gotten death threats.
Is that right? Yeah, dude. And those death threats are specifically
related to the issues with Pink. Is that correct? It's definitely
like has a big snowball effect, dude. A huge, dude. Huge.
Okay. So, you do blame the current death threats that you were
getting and are they a direct result of my client's statement
back in November of 2024 on her subc count? I would absolutely
say they are one of from the root causes as well as the exasperation.
Tech tone. You're telling me that you get death threats from
something that she subweeted two years ago ago. Not the fact
that you [__]
>> It's all the right-wing grift. It wasn't even that.
That was something people would bring up. It was something by
the way. No, no, no. It's not even both. It's actually not. It's
actually not both. King of Wit. It's not both. It's literally
him being a complete to people all the time, being one of the
most costic on the internet. Okay. And people are just taking
his the thing he said makes him most upset, which is getting
called a thing he keeps saying makes him the most upset in the
world, and they're throwing that in his face over and over and
over again. Right? That is what he is actually upset about is
the fact that these people are taking the thing that he said
makes him upset, throwing it in his face. He's blaming it all
on her. But it is actually just him being a on the internet that
makes everybody want to do that. It's not It's not that she caused
it. He caused it and she did the thing that actually hurts him
and he points out to everybody. That really hurts me. That really
upsets me. That really upsets me. So because he's a to everybody
else trying to hurt them that people go, "Oh, what hurts this
guy?" Being called a ringtone
epigenetic memories of
Okay, that's what's happening. [__] do right-wing
politics and grift all day and just attack Assan and attack everyone
with lies and you don't know what you're talking about. You don't
think that has anything to do with that? That you're constantly
attacking things and saying things that aren't just about some
piece of [__] to everybody on the >> You don't
know what you're talking about to a massive audience of lies
of deceit of things that you don't understand. You're saying
to a massive audience that can that can affect things that you
were just lying about some serious things about other people's
lives. Don't think that's what's doing a tech tone. You think
it's because of Pink Jew from 2 years ago? >> You see how
Donut Operator and Brandon Herrera haven't came out defending
him? Oh, they won't. Now, this is like the biggest thing is obviously
him lying about the schizophrenia. Bro, where are the big tweets
about this? I that where are the big tweets about this? This
is massive. Am I going to be the person who goes and lays out
how uh he's obviously lying in tweets and just get like a million
view tweet again? Am I going to have to be the one who goes and
lays this out? Cuz it's obviously like a huge tweet for anybody
who wants to lay this
It's like so obvious. It's insanely obvious that this guy's like
just completely lying about his mental illness. Dude, there's
no
I'm sure some clipping account. This to me is like the biggest
one. Where is it? Where is it? Where is it? I literally don't
I don't see it. I'm scrolling. I'm scrolling looking. Okay, this
this did just pop up on my feed though. Okay, totally unrelated,
but this did just pop up on my feed.
Charlie Kirk and Candace Owens.
>> Oh, okay.
Hello. I know,
>> dude. I'm sorry. So,
sorry that just popped up on my feed. Goofy as but very funny.
Okay.
Unrelated random pallet cleanser. I'm just looking for people
talking about the lying about schizophrenia treatment. The lying
about schizophrenia. How is that not getting laid out is like
one of the biggest things here that Tech has to answer for. By
the way, he can answer for this regardless of any court case.
This could be answered. This could be talked about regardless
of any court case, regardless of any court order. This is something
he could talk about. Hey, what the is going on with your mental
illness? Okay. Well, I guess in 3 hours when I end the stream,
I'll go and tweet about it and try to figure this >> cuz
this is insane. >> I would absolutely put on Twitter for
me or whatever as well as an exasperation.
Okay, so it doesn't have anything to do with your current white
privilege comments and propaganda and racist towards whites.
That has uh nothing to do with your death threats. Is that correct?
So, if I can explain on that, um, when all those things came
out, I lost pretty much a large chunk of my audience. And content
creators because she stopped buying my viewbots and content creators
have to pivot what they're doing to other topics or they'll lose
access to a demographic. Hold on. He lost a he lost a large chunk
of his audience. E, hold on.
Hold on. Sully
Not Hassanabi, but Teto.
Let's look at the audience chunk he lost. 365 days. We'll start
there.Oop
boop.
He lost a large chunk of audience. Where? November 2024.
November 20th, 2024. He's getting around 4,000.
Okay,
hold on. Let's go like this. Let's go back to November.
I'm losing it here. Right here. Right here. Right here. Is this
good? No. Here we go.
I lost a big chunk of audience in November of 2024.
where did you lose a big chunk of
You literally have your biggest streams right here and then you
took like a week off and you took like after a week off you took
a hit of
200 300 live viewers like 10%. And you're right back to normal.
You're totally fine.
You even talking about dude? You didn't lose. He's just lying.
Well, it's because he's bought it. Maybe it's because he's bought
it. He's just lying about this. It's literally just a complete
and utter lie. He didn't lose audience. It's just another lie.
It's just another like self victimization. I would not be shocked
if he really believed this, by the way. It is just him in victim.
He's in victim mode. He's just going to say the things he thinks
he has to say he should say in this case, right? He's just self
victimizing. Again,
originally I I never really covered anything political or talked
about anything political, you know, like white privilege. It's
sick. You you got to try it out. But yeah, I would say my content
definitely had to find a new route on how to be successful online.
And so unfortunately, because I hate what I do right now, but
I do it anyway, I had to make a little bit more extreme comments
to be successful in the career that I'm in now.
Well, and that's as recent as >> Oh god, he actually leans
into the right-wing grifting stuff as hard as I I thought they
exaggerated. I actually thought they were exaggerating, but he
is literally just laying out how he started grifting, bro. Ely
because I hate what I do right now, but I do it anyway. I had
to make a little bit more extreme comment.
>> Never really covered anything political. >> To
be successful in the career that I'm in now,
>> he literally admits it under oath. I >> And that's
as recent as October 2025 that you were making statements with
regards to white supremacy and people being racist against white
people. Is that correct?
>> Just to make sure, are you saying that I'm a white supremacist?
Is that what you're saying?
>> I'm asking about your post with regarding what? What
the did I say? >> Asking you about what your post is regarding
maybe. >> Okay. Let's talk about October 28th, 2025. So
I think who is Valkyrie? I mean, she's like a very successful
content creator. >> Whoa. Wall. That's what he means. Okay.
Wall.
Rabbit clock. Rabbit. Rabbit clock. Rabbit clock. Rabbit clock.
[__] Wall. Wall. Wall. >> Creating one of the
largest leftist political content creators in the world. Listen,
dude. I'm going to say Pink's name, but I'll never [__]
speak that
Turkish [__] piece of Okay, so yes, I can't say her
name. Uh, Valkare. If you treat someone different or assume someone's
passes based on their race, that's racist. Yes, even to white
people. Is that correct? Yeah. For some reason, the internet
believes that if you judge someone based on their skin color,
it's bad unless you're white. Um, and then it's okay. So, I've
talked about that briefly um on the internet
>> I'm just saying that it's uh it's okay to be white,
guys. Okay? It's it's okay to be white, you know. You know, it's
okay to be white. Uh I didn't think that was such a crazy thing
to say, but uh it's okay to be white. >> Maybe a little
bit more than briefly at this point. Like, [__]
And you refer to Assan, who is another streamer, as a terror
supporter and a dog abuser.
looks like Her lawyer brought up Hassan first. Technically, okay.
Technically, he brought up Hassan first by saying left it biggest
leftest streamer. But that's her lawyer bringing up Hassan. Yeah,
he electrocuted that thing.
Like, did you see that dude like dude threw a toaster at that
and he says Bullah was doing a good thing and I don't even think
supporting terrorism nor abuse your animals, right?
White privilege is propaganda the real racists have been using
to be racist towards whites for things they never did for decades.
You posted that on October 27th of 225. Is that right? Yeah,
that's pretty accurate. Okay. But the death threats are originated
because of my client's post.
Hey, you're tweeting some say I told you. I knew it. I knew he
was going hardcore right-wing griff before this happened. This
is this is why I didn't believe this when he said it. He's trying
to say that she's the reason, she's the cause. The lawyer has
brought receipts,
right? The lawyer has brought receipts of the fact that he is
making insane statements that would get him death threats way
before she made any tweets at all. You've hallucinated that she's
the cause. You want to blame her for all this. You are wrong.
You are completely wrong, Techtoad. You are full of [__]
Right. Everything he's been arguing about how it was her fault
that he's called a racist. Totally wrong. Sorry. Not racist.
C not P not C. P not C >> post where she didn't name you.
>> So the fact that he's getting death threats obviously
that has way more to do with the fact that you were being a right-wing
before this. In fact, you acting like you had to pivot your content.
You did that before my client tweeted anything. Correct.
Correct.
>> In November of 2024.
Wait, hold on. It does say 2025. Whoops.
You're right. You're right. You're right. I misread the date.
I thought she was cooking. Listen, listen, listen, listen, listen,
listen, listen.
We're 11 hours into the stream. That's my bad. That's my bad.
I thought I was cooking. >> Sorry. We are 11 hours into
the stream. Little bit little bit e although I feel energized.
Uh my bad.
I think
it's it serves the same purpose. weaker point though, like obviously
you tweet, you know, very very incendiary things
and
that is probably contributing to you getting death threats way
more than um anything else. I thought it was before
>> Yeah, you >> wait, are we sure you posted that
in October 2025? Do we not have anything in
>> No, all the son stuff is 2025. But the death threats
are originated because of my client's post where she didn't name
you in November of 2024. Is that right?
Yeah. You can check the timestamp on the threats if you like.
Like, I'll give you some time, sweet, sweet Jason.
Oh.
Oh,
I think she's going to walk back in the same direction. I think
I think this will go back before. I'm positive he was starting
his like right-wing son grift way before this stuff popped off.
How about your stance on trans children? Has that gotten you
death threats? Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. So, that didn't come from my client, correct? Correct.
But those are far after this whole ordeal happened.
Okay. But upon questioning from your lawyer, you blamed my client
for those death threats. >> Technone calls Froggen jab
the hut and says she causes issues for no reason.
This was one year ago, May 19th, 2024.
I knew he'd started it way before. Okay. He was starting to get
way more aggressive on this [__] before any of the
allegations.
Okay,
I I knew this was the case. I knew he started to [__]
these people and it was slowly getting like more of that more
like adjacent to Asmin Gold over time. It's pretty obvious, man.
So, listen. My >> How many times are you going to lie under
oath? >> Watch it happen. >> Yeah. Well, for the
ones in regards to me being arrested, of course. Why wouldn't
I? >> Okay. I don't think people like there. I said it.
Are we done with this?
>> Okay, so he's now he's going to say actually the death
threats for being called where I'm called a those are the ones
I attribute to her. Maybe that's a little better. Maybe that's
a little more accurate. Right. >> Okay. And I think just
kind of to wrap things up, you originally talked about being
authentic with your audience and you unfortunately have had a
salt experience yourself and I'm so sorry for that.
Thank you, dude. Thank you. Techone loves her again. Oh, you
just validated me as a victim. Thank you. Oh, thank you. I was
worried I wasn't getting through. >> An eye for an eye,
I say. Let's go, EVERYBODY. COME ON. >> MUCHOS, COME ON.
ON ME. LET'S GO, EVERYONE. COME ON. FREE. GET IN THE CAR. >> HEY,
STOP.
>> And it's okay for you to talk about that public. Is
that right? >> Of course. So then why is it okay for you
to talk about your experiences, but my client cannot talk about
her experiences when she doesn't name you? Damn. Oh
no.
Oh
Hey, why can you talk about your sexual assault?
But my client can't talk about what she thinks is her sexual
assault. Well, uh, that's cuz she's a lying and I'm like a based
victim gigachad
who doesn't eat the box. So, have you thought about that? Have
you thought about that? >> That is a very good question.
That is a
good question.
>> Pinky. Pinky's lawyer
went sicko mode on this guy. I've never seen somebody get raped
this brutally. Holy. Like in a legal sense.
Like this is up there with the um
the guy from that trial in Boston in Boston
where that woman backed into or didn't back into that murder
trial. It's up with up there with that lawyer who is like doing
all kinds of [__] who was really good in the examination.
I can't remember any of the names now. Karen Reed. The Karen
Reed case. Okay. This is up there with that lawyer. Like she's
she's crushing these people. She tone really these >> people.
Techone. >> Good question. She buttered him up. Damn. She
got him. She buttered him up
>> Oh yeah. I love this. This is awesome. Tech Tones is
still Ms. 6 hours into
His girlfriend like still.
Yes.
Hold on. Hold on. Uh hold on. MSI, if you're still going, you're
still doing
>> I need sleep really badly. >> It's the funniest
thing I've ever read in my life. She buttered him up cuz she
knew that he would want to talk about it and he was probably
ready for to grab a tissue. And then she said,
"So then why is it okay for you to talk about your experiences,
but my CL can't talk about her experiences when she doesn't even
name you?" >> Hi chat. Hi chat.
Well, one, because it didn't happen, and two, because everyone
knew who she was referring to. Okay, as you can tell by the viral
tweets. All right. And tell me this. Did you ever make her >> I'm
sorry. I'm like starting to hear her voice the same way I hear
um Mantis's. Like, she has Mantis's voice, too. >> The
right words on her face when you gave her a >> Oh, Jesus.
How did she get there? What?
Uh, well, one, because it didn't happen, and two, because everybody
knew who she was referring to. Okay. As you can tell by the viral
tweets. All right. Tell me this. Did you ever make her write
words?
>> Okay. And how many times did you record her? A lot.
>> Okay. And how many times did she tell you no? I don't
want to be recorded. Never. She didn't even know about it. How
many times did she actually agree to be recorded? Every time.
She would even hold the camera. Okay. It was like playing Pokemon
Snapdude and I was finding a Moltres in the lava. It was sick.
Like every Wait. Oh, what do you mean? She'd be okay.
This is now getting really weird.
What did What did you think about Techtoad? Hey,
listen. If it'll get you to my You can me you can pretend to
me. Okay, I know that's like I know you know with your genetics
that's what you need so you can pretend to me. Okay, I just want
to get off one time. TEONE, PLEASE. PLEASE, TETO, FOR FOR THE
LOVE OF GOD, MAN. I know you need this. I know >> because
she was so forward about wanting to have uh the intercourse.
She told me that it would be
lawyer. What did you what did you write here? Okay. Okay. If
I just
Meanwhile, Misk's Misk's girlfriend's over here like, "Oh, is
it I don't even know if this is his girlfriend." She's like,
"Bro,
speaking of wanting to provide pleasure, can we go do something?
You've been on this guy's for like 14 hours a day for the past
week, man. Can we Can we go hang out? >> not his girlfriend.
I'm sorry. It's not his girlfriend. She seems nice. I'm not I'm
The Mantis thing isn't even talking. It's just genuinely I think
she actually looks like the Mantis character.
Like I genuinely think this she looks like this character. Not
with the eyes. Like you replace the eyes, but otherwise exact
same person. >> He was sleeping.
I didn't mean to say that. I was just saying, you know, we would,
you know, try different outfits just to see. I was like, you
ever watched like the Bratz or something, dude? Like they're
slamming, but um, you know, does this make things exciting? >> Hold
on. Hold on. I need to back it up. Watch him go to watch it go
to something, dude. Like, >> oh, that was so perfect. >> Um,
you know, does this make things
>> Like focuses on her like unbelieving
>> Oh, sorry. That was awesome. How's an outfit the same
as writing
derogatory statements on someone's face to come here? >> I
guess I didn't really see it as degrading and it was kind of
just both of our idea just to make the things fun in the bedroom,
dude. >> So, it isn't that maybe the problem, Mr. Robertson,
that she views what you did as non-consensual and you just don't
see it that way.
>> Bro, he is so unprepared. I'm sorry.
Am I the only one? I don't want to I'm not sure for Techone.
I
He could easily answer this in a way that does not paint him
out as bad as he's making himself out to be. Like I'm sorry.
Yeah. Yeah. His like his lawyer didn't prepare him for anything.
He's just not prepared at all. He is like totally unprepared.
He didn't put any work into this whatsoever. He's just been off
doing who knows what.
Like no wonder he got destroyed here.
Like all he should be saying here, his answer should be
listen um it was consensual. She wrote she wrote that stuff herself.
It was totally consensual and she never expressed any like if
he has to like he could just it's a closed room, right? Like
he should just say she it was just you know consensual adults
in a bedroom. Um, you can say it was degrading, but it was something
we were both interested in. And he's saying it now kind of, but
like he's just letting these It's like, no, I I didn't see this
as derogatory. It was just something we were into. I didn't see
it as derogatory or demeaning. It was something we were both
into.
>> I think if I was ever informed a single time that things
were uncomfortable or she didn't like what she was doing, I would
immediately say, "Well, then let's not do it." To be completely
honest, I'm not really a guy at all. Don't really need it.
I just like do like photosynthesis and that's all I do all day.
>> Okay,
wait.
Wait, but that's not true. You actually would sit her down with
a whiteboard and go Oh, no. >> Okay, but that's not true.
You actually would sit her down with a whiteboard and go over
everything to convince her that she was wrong, right?
>> Um, well, I'm afraid to see how that connects, but I
have don't understand what you do in what regard. We have talked
with a whiteboard before. So, Teone here is trying to say he
doesn't really care about, but he would, for some reason, for
a guy that doesn't care about would constantly go over consensual,
non-consensual with her under a whiteboard.
Yeah. And you would use a whiteboard to show her that she was
wrong in whatever position she was taking that you all were disagreeing
on. Correct.
Oh, dude. If we were to have an argument, then we would weren't
seeing eye. Visual aid really helped her as well as to me. Really
helped. Okay. And do you know what coercive control is? Yeah.
And
>> wait, he does. Wait, how did he say yes to that?
You know what course of control is? Yes.
>> You told her that. >> It's weird that he said
yes to that. How does he know about course of control? He doesn't
know about his own schizophrenia. He knows nothing about his
own diagnosed medical mental illness, but he knows about course
of >> She had memory problems. I believe we had discussions
of her memory not being, you know, as sharp as attack. Sure.
I'm sure uh we've had conversations about memories. Um I tried
to make her forget about that. I have a
Okay. And because you believe that her >> Did he cut out
for microction because of what she is saying? >> Wait,
by the way, hold on, hold on. By the way, I thought we were going
to get testimony here that he was microone. I have not seen the
microphone testimony.
Have I missed the microphone testimony?
Because it seems like we're missing out on the microphone testimony.
I know Tetone himself has has testified to his microphone, but
and Bream has, but I thought we're getting additional microphone
testimony that I have not >> My dick is a person, ma'am.
Do I believe her current memory of what happened between us is
incorrect? Yeah, dude. Absolutely. I have it on video. I mean,
um I I do believe it's incorrect. Yes. Your ex-wife made some
pretty awful allegations against you, didn't >> your ex-wife
made some pretty awful allegations against you, didn't she? She
did, but she admitted they were all lies. Well, now remember,
you have an NDA. So, so remember Teone's lawyer cannot talk about
this. And also, Frame can't either. So, him saying she admitted
to it is under not is not true. He can't say that. Oh, it's in
the court order. Okay. We had some pretty serious allegations.
Yes. That she made against you. Uh, and that's so you learn from
That tone violated the protective order already. What?
I'm looking at something in my Discord. This guy said this is
a protective order violation in the Discord, but it's not. It's
2025, not 2026.
Protective order wasn't in place until August of this year. Oh,
that's quite a while ago. Maybe somebody corrected them. I was
backed up in the Discord. >> From that marriage, what can
happen when false allegations Well, not false. I don't know if
they were true or not, but you know how to handle allegations
like that from your first marriage. Correct. I don't think I
handled those pretty well. I think I handled those pretty bad.
So, Teto admits that he did a very bad job in his first marriage
and that he should probably have learned from that from his first
marriage.
But you definitely knew how to handle it when you had my client
in your house, right? I was kind of a mess when that happened
to be honest with you. Well, then tell me this. How many times
did you go with her to any of her therapy appointments? I don't
think I was invited. Okay. Did you tell her and tell her what
things to get the therapist to get prescribed certain medications?
I definitely tried to help her understand, you know, just try
to help her make sense of what's going on in her head. You know,
she wanted to tell me this is kind of happening and I'd say,
"Well, maybe it's this." I definitely tried to help her in her
journey to therapy and meditate medication, bro. And what pharmaceutical
background do you have to give her any
>> Sorry, mischiev.
Oh, I'm not qualified, but I don't think would try to help their
partner without >> I keep seeing it. >> But yet,
you couldn't help yourself with your own.
>> Oh my god, you destroyed destroyed. Destroyed. Destroyed.
>> Hey, didn't we just establish you're a total with regards
to mental illness and medications? Why the were you even trying
to give your your help at all? That would be disastrous, brother.
>> Absolutely destroyed. Absolutely
destroyed.
He would try to tell her what medications to take. >> No,
Misk is saying, "Bro, he's making it >> So, you're going
to tell my client what to do, but you can't do it for yourself.
You are willing to constantly let my client tell her what medication
she needs to take, but you can't take medications of your own.
And your reason why is you haven't even been to therapy. You
haven't even seen psychosis. You just get behind a fire with
your friends and talk it out.
But you force your girlfriend to go and get what is needed that
you think is prescribable and what she needs to get when you
have no background whatsoever. This isn't him telling her to
take a Tylenol. This is not him telling him to take an Advil.
This is not him saying that this helped me and that this can
help you. This is him literally saying that this is stuff you
should be taking that I don't know what the [__]
they'll do, but you need to take it cuz he doesn't take anything.
So, we can't be like,
>> I want
this person to ask what medications he he recommended specifically.
>> Yeah. Well, it really helped me and I think we have
similar things. So, I tried to help her. He doesn't take so he
literally is just going to online or somewhere and just figuring
this out on his own and just changing how she feels where she
would shake and have quivers and couldn't think straight. But
yet, you couldn't help yourself with your own. Yeah. as a result
of poor, you know, poor experiences with my own medication.
I passed the witness. Mr. Porier, anything else? No, your honor.
The court, Mr. Robertson, you could return to your attorney at
the table. Please call your net witness.
Holy [__]
Absolutely
destroyed. Not even not even
destroyed. Destroyed. Teone, you got destroyed. You destroyed
yourself in half of all this because you just had to go on tangents.
But she
dude,
he actually
it's it's so over.
But this is this is I pass the witness for anything else. No,
your honor.
We rest at this point. There are no further witnesses. Dude,
I think
I legitimately think if you show this transcript to another attorney,
I don't even think I think he could shop less for an attorney
to go after these attorneys for malpractice than he had to shop
around the original lawsuit or the original um civil case to
other attorneys, right? I think he could easily find an attorney
who's like, "Yeah, you were not prepared. Yeah, you were Yeah,
you got [__] over. Okay, dude. No preparation. Absolutely
mogged the entire time." Like
we thought five versus one it was going to be like uh David versus
Goliath or something. Dude, Pink's lawyer mogged these the entire
time. It wasn't close. She ran circles around these. >> She
destroyed you cuz you admitted it. And there it is. Ch. I proved
to you that he admits that he would tell her what to take. He
would admit that he doesn't take anything for her schizophrenia.
He would admit that he does therapy and he doesn't. He would
admit that he would he would course her into things. He admitted
to all of it. everything. It doesn't make sense. Techone, why
would you still have those videos? And why did you have those
videos if she didn't like them?
It made no sense. That is insane. And he lied three times under
oath. This guy who acts like he loves the uh right-wing politics
and all. He lied under oath. And he literally admits he griffs
because of al >> read the lawyer's trial summary. What
is that, Kirsty? >> He straight up admitted he doesn't
like what he does, but he does it cuz he has to. So, anytime
TeeOne ever does anything, just remember he doesn't want to do
it. He does it cuz he has to do it because of what apparently
she did. And then he's like, "Yeah, dude. She called me a She
said I assaulted her." So, like
um we don't actually know there was no prep. I mean, I'm telling
you that there's no evidence of prep. Okay. This guy looks like
he's totally unprepared. He doesn't know how to answer. They
didn't There's no way that they walked him through how to do
the original like direct examination and he just ignored them,
right? I just I don't see why you would. Why even pay attorneys?
Just show up represent a pedophile and now it's still six, man.
It's like, dude, no. Like, you're called a piece of because you
do right-wing politics. He got actually owned. He got actually
destroyed. It's crazy. >> All right, so back to this. >> She
passes it to the the court, the the torch to Mr. Porier, who
is Tech's lawyer. We rest at this point, your honor. All right,
both sides have rested. Mrs. Lock. Yes, judge. I don't know if
you want me to turn any fees by submission. Uh, go ahead. Okay,
so this >> Wait, what? >> It was techone. >> I
don't know if you want me to do attorney's fees by submission
or testify to them. I got to pull up. She already knows. Pig's
lawyers already knows I'm getting paid by these. How do you want
me to submit my bill to you so you can verify it? Your honor,
you want to you want me to, you know, affidavit?
Uh, do I do it like I just testify to what my bills were?
>> Lawyer, we rest at this point, your honor. All right.
Both sides have rested. Mrs. Lock. Yes, judge. I don't know if
you want me to fees by submission. Uh, go ahead. Okay. So, this
is his lawyer, her lawyer basically saying the amount of to legal
fees that have been going on. Um, and that's what's happening.
Oh, hold on,
dude. Dude, absolutely cooked.
Absolutely cooked. Please read the whole statement. Yes. Thank
you. Yes. I'm going to briefly close. Give you the opportunity
to briefly close. Dude, this
>> What has happened today is a reason why more victims
of assault don't come forward. What she had to go through exemplifies
why it is so difficult for victims to come assert their rights.
Because they get painted as liars, as overly aggressive women,
as women with boob jobs and lip filler and everything done to
degrade them as individual person as opposed listening to their
>> Yeah, 100%. Just a stupid only fans. But the next part
is >> I think that it is terrifying that we have someone
who has been diagnosed with schizophrenia, admits to delusions
of what sees at least once a month and goes untreated while he
may not have firearms in his possession right now because I don't
think he can under the current temporary protective order. The
concern is what happens when you've got an unmedicated person
who is schizophrenic diagnosed with schizophrenia.
>> Bro, I knew this would get hammered. Oh my god, it's
the thing I've been hammering on over and over again. unmedicated
unmedicated
diagnosed schizophrenic who has talked multiple times about his
hallucinations.
It's
>> Doesn't get treatment has admitted to his fans himself
that he becomes paranoid and that he sees things. I mean, he
saw her face melting according to her testimony. I I don't I
don't think her story is believable. I think it is concerning
and I think Mr. Robertson misses what went wrong. I do believe
some of the acts were non-consensual. I do believe the testimony
is credible with regards to that. He literally admits it on stream.
If the court looks at the medical records that were introduced,
it shows that she went for blank in May and then had to get it
dissolved back in September. Several months later, which coincides
with the timing of the incident and testifies to put forward
in her decoration, we think it's appropriate in this particular
case to grant a protective order because just what occurred,
you saw him ramp up, threatened to go nuclear, said we're going
to war, and kept escalating and talking about her, talking about
the case, talking about issues until the August 8th. Bro, it's
actually Dude, they uno reversed the mentally illit. They totally
uno reversed it. Except Tetone looks a hund times worse for basically
laying out all the schizophrenia stuff along with all of his
like
anime villain monologues about how we're going to war, we're
going nuclear, I'm going to you're you will be destroyed like
all of this. It paints a sinister picture. And then he has his
own testified, hasn't bothered her, hasn't texted her, hasn't
done anything. Why? Because the protective order served its purpose.
I mean, to me, that is proof in the pudding. Uh that is as clear
as mud that my client absolutely needs the protective order for
a period of time that the court determines appropriate so that
these parties can go to their separate corners and go live their
lives without any further concerns for reputations, repercussions
online for their especially for their client for her respective
earnings. So we'd ask respectfully that the court grant and protective
order and aware the attorney fees are requested.
Thank you Miss Lockach. Mr. Porier.
Damn. So she uses the fact that Teone has undiagnosed schizophrenia
against him because he's trying to farm people from feeling sad
for him that he has undiagnosed schizophrenia. He li >> sorry
unmedicated >> lied about the fact that he goes to therapy.
He's lied about basically everything he tried to say there. Everything
was a lie and doesn't course with his story. And she,
>> by the way, I don't believe that he has diagnosed schizophrenia.
I don't believe that he actually went I I believe to get a schizophrenia
diagnosis, you need more than one appointment, okay? With with
one psychiatrist.
All right. M was right at this point. Yeah, I'm fried, too. I
don't blame him, okay? I don't blame him. He did fantastic work
here. This is an awesome stream. Another awesome stream. All
right. We love Miz here.
I don't believe that this guy has schizophrenia. I think he's
made it up. You cannot get a solid schizophrenia diagnosis from
one thing, however many years ago, and say that, "Yeah, I'm a
diagnosed schiz off, man." No shot. All right. Now,
it's is it not poetic justice that he he couldn't admit that
he just made this up? that he was just lying because he's clearly
stacked so many dominoes in his personal life using this as an
excuse that if he were to admit he's lying here and say no I
don't and and have a shot at this case right he would be he would
destroy himself as a streamer in his personal life he would be
right so he can't admit the lie he's got to continue to go with
it and he looks absolutely deranged as a result and I can't think
of any more like poetic uh like anything more poetically
justified. I can't think of anything a better example of poetic
justice. There we go. I can't think of a better example of poetic
justice than Tees lie about schizophrenia that has piled up on
it for him for years, right?
that's what finally cooks him in court here in my opinion is
like, yeah, this guy's clearly a danger. like he this testimony
he has proven to us that he is a danger to himself and others.
>> All right, chat. This is the end. Last four pages.
All right, here we go.
This is the court ruling. Keep in mind there's a lot of things
we didn't see, chat, because we couldn't see because they were
graphics or things. There's a lot of this court case that we
just didn't get to see. So, there's a lot of things that uh are
not there. Okay.
um which are probably making Tekken look way worse because she
didn't talk about him at all and Tech wouldn't shut up about
her after he got the cease to desist. Keep in mind that was the
problem is he got a cease and desist and he wouldn't shut up
based on the testimony and evidence that's been provided on the
court.
Ladies and gentlemen, we have our
>> Oh my god. Based on the testimony and the evidence that's
been provided to the court, the court does find that there is
reasonable grounds to believe that the applicant is the victim
of assault. The court makes the additional finding that there
are reasonable grounds to believe that the applicant is the victim
of stalking and will grant a 10-year protective order. It will
expire at midnight January 23rd, 2036
and will contain the terms and conditions that have been requested
by the applicant and their attorney fees for $15,000 will be
awarded to the applicant. What I want to say, Mr.
>> just right here.
Packatch on techone. Now, she's totally found in favor of the
applicant. That is pink. All right.
Now the judge is going to directly address
the newly dubbed. Okay. He told her it was techone but it is
not. It is now.
>> Yes ma'am. You are not allowed to have any contact with
her in the manner whatsoever. That means no contact through phone
calls, emails, mail, text messages, any kind of social media,
any kind of communication with her throughout third parties.
All that is prohibited. You can only communicate with her through
attorneys.
In addition, you are to stay 200 yards away from her in any address
where you know her to be in including her residence her work
>> like this next part. >> If you run into her outside
of those locations, you need to turn around and leave if you
get there first. >> Yes, ma'am. >> The court she
cannot give you permission to violate those orders. If for some
reason within the 10-year period she calls you or or communicates
with you that she has changed her mind and it's okay for you
to come by her residence, it wouldn't it would not be a valid
defense to a criminal charge or violation of protective order
that she gave you permission to come over because only a judge
or a court can change or modify this protective order. That's
interesting. I didn't know that. In addition, you are not to
be in possession of any firearms or ammunition while this order
is in effect. I'm going to ask you to relinquish any firearms
in your possession within 24 hours to law enforcement and provide
a receipt of relinquishment to Mrs. Mrs. Lockach within 48 hours.
If you do not possess if you do not possess or own any firearms
as you testified to, then you may provide a sworn affidavit indicating
as such and that also needs to be provided to Mrs. Lock within
24 hours.
How do you think Teone felt saying this? Yes, ma'am.
I'm also going to order you and I don't know that you specifically
asked for this, Mrs. block. So in e added, but you are not to
dis uh disseminate or reproduce or share any kind of photographic
or electronic or digital media that is a recording of this applicant.
And I think you know what I'm talking about. It's been referenced
many times during this proceeding that is completely prohibited.
Yes, ma'am.
The court was there anything else, Mrs. Lockach, that you were
Mrs. Lockach, the only reason is because it's Friday. Can we
have make him do everything on Monday? That's fine. And I can
get an order to the court on Monday, but I need a copy of the
specific ruling so I can put it in the ruling. The court. Okay,
that's fine. We could take care of the actual order on Monday.
But just so you understand, just because you don't have a physical
order,
had to wait till Wednesday because of the snow >> hand
does not mean that these orders are not in place. They are currently
in full force in effect. This is a protective order is valid
and enforceable not just for Travis County and in Texas, but
across all 50 states. So, no matter where she moves, no matter
where you move, it is valid and enforceable until January 23rd,
2036 when GTA 6 is finally released. Thank you. We're off the
record. Court is recess.
Everyone, you can get up.
>> 255 pages later. 225 pages later, I read the entire
thing. You're all out of
>> Oh my god. Thank god we made it through the entire thing
now. All right, guys. We watch the whole thing. Oh my god, my
body hurts. My body hurts.
All right. Yeah. W stream.